Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered.
Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered.|||感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。还有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石纹理完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？那就是由 Instacart 采购员精心挑选并送到你门前、在烧烤架上滋滋作响的大理石纹理肋眼牛排。甚至不用离开儿童戏水池，就能下单买到大理石纹理的肋眼牛排。无论你的夏天需要什么食材，Instacart 都能满足你。
Download the Instacart app and enjoy zero dollar delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart. Groceries that over-deliver. I saw His Majesty King Charles XII, a great way off, with a suite of some fifty horsemen, riding along a column of wagons. His Majesty came at last to mine, and inquired who I was. The Colonel replied, This is the unfortunate ensign Piper of the guards, whose feet were frostbitten.
Download the Instacart app and enjoy zero dollar delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart. Groceries that over-deliver. I saw His Majesty King Charles XII, a great way off, with a suite of some fifty horsemen, riding along a column of wagons. His Majesty came at last to mine, and inquired who I was. The Colonel replied, This is the unfortunate ensign Piper of the guards, whose feet were frostbitten.|||下载 Instacart 应用，前三单即可享受零美元配送费。服务费、排除条款和适用条款均有约束。Instacart。超越期待的杂货配送。我远远地看见国王查理十二世陛下，带着大约五十名骑兵随从，沿着一列马车骑行。陛下终于来到了我的马车旁，询问我是谁。上校回答说：这是禁卫军不幸的旗手派珀，他的双脚冻伤了。
His Majesty then rode up close beside the wagon and asked me, How is it with you? I replied, Ill enough, Your Majesty, for I cannot stand upon either foot. He then rode up close beside the wagon and asked me, How is it with you? I replied, Ill enough, your majesty, for I cannot stand upon either foot. His majesty asked, Have you lost part of your feet? I told him that heels and toes were gone, and to this he said, A trifle, a trifle. And resting his own leg upon the pommel of his saddle, he pointed to half the soul, saying, I have seen men who lost this much of their foot, and when they had stuffed their boot, they walked as well as before.
His Majesty then rode up close beside the wagon and asked me, How is it with you? I replied, Ill enough, Your Majesty, for I cannot stand upon either foot. He then rode up close beside the wagon and asked me, How is it with you? I replied, Ill enough, your majesty, for I cannot stand upon either foot. His majesty asked, Have you lost part of your feet? I told him that heels and toes were gone, and to this he said, A trifle, a trifle. And resting his own leg upon the pommel of his saddle, he pointed to half the soul, saying, I have seen men who lost this much of their foot, and when they had stuffed their boot, they walked as well as before.|||陛下随后骑马走到马车近旁，问我：“你感觉怎么样？”我回答说：“很不好，陛下，因为我的双脚都无法站立。”他随后骑马走到马车近旁，问我：“你感觉怎么样？”我回答说：“很不好，陛下，因为我的双脚都无法站立。”陛下问：“你失去部分脚掌了吗？”我告诉他脚跟和脚趾都没了，对此他说：“小事一桩，小事一桩。”说着，他将自己的腿搭在马鞍头上，指着半个鞋底说道：“我见过失去这么多脚掌的人，当他们在靴子里塞满东西后，他们走起路来和以前一样好。”
Turning then to the Colonel, His Majesty asked, perhaps he will run again. The Colonel replied, He may thank his God if he can so much as walk. He must not think of running. As His Majesty rode away, he said to the Colonel, He is to be pitied, for he is so young. So that was Ensign Gustav Piper of the Swedish Guards who had lost both his heels and most of his toes to frostbite talking to Mr. Motivator himself, Charles the 12th of Sweden in April 1709. It's a trifle, a trifle. I love that. Half his foot gone.
Turning then to the Colonel, His Majesty asked, perhaps he will run again. The Colonel replied, He may thank his God if he can so much as walk. He must not think of running. As His Majesty rode away, he said to the Colonel, He is to be pitied, for he is so young. So that was Ensign Gustav Piper of the Swedish Guards who had lost both his heels and most of his toes to frostbite talking to Mr. Motivator himself, Charles the 12th of Sweden in April 1709. It's a trifle, a trifle. I love that. Half his foot gone.|||接着，陛下转向上校问：“也许他还能跑吧。”上校回答说：“他能走路就该感谢上帝了。他可别妄想跑步。”当陛下骑马离开时，他对上校说：“他太年轻了，真令人怜悯。”这就是瑞典禁卫军旗手古斯塔夫·派珀，他因冻伤失去了双脚脚跟和大部分脚趾，于1709年4月与“励志大师”本人——瑞典的查理十二世交谈。小事一桩，小事一桩。我太喜欢这个了。半只脚都没了。
Dominic, this is classic territory for armies that invade Russia, isn't it? Soldiers losing their feet to frostbite, probably kind of eating straw, all that kind of thing. Yeah, we think that now, but they didn't think that then. So, um, if you remember, we are in the frozen grip of the great Northern war, the great struggle, the Titanic showdown between Peter the great of Russia and Charles the 12th of Sweden for mastery of the North and the East of Europe. And, um, when Charles set off, if you remember, everybody was terribly optimistic
Dominic, this is classic territory for armies that invade Russia, isn't isn't it? Soldiers losing their feet to frostbite, probably kind of eating straw, all that kind of thing. Yeah, we think that now, but they didn't think that then. So, um, if you remember, we are in the frozen grip of the great Northern war, the great struggle, the Titanic showdown between Peter the great of Russia and Charles the 12th of Sweden for mastery of the North and the East of Europe. And, um, when Charles set off, if you remember, everybody was terribly optimistic|||多米尼克，这是入侵俄罗斯军队的经典遭遇，对吧？士兵因冻伤失去双脚，可能还在吃稻草之类的。是的，我们现在这么认为，但他们当时并不这么想。所以，嗯，如果大家还记得的话，我们正处于大北方战争的冰冷魔掌之中，这是一场伟大的斗争，是俄国的彼得大帝与瑞典的查理十二世为了争夺欧洲北部和东部的统治权而展开的世纪大对决。而且，嗯，如果大家记得的话，当查理出发时，所有人都极其乐观。
and there was no thought of frostbite or missing toes and heels. Certainly no thought of stuffing a boot with straw to make up for the loss of your foot. They would be celebrating in the Kremlin. That was the plan. That's what they thought. So listeners will remember from the last episode that Peter had seized part of the Baltic coast and he'd founded his new city of St. Petersburg amid the bogs and marshes. But all the momentum seemed to lie with the ultimate Scandinavian.
and there was no thought of frostbite or missing toes and heels. Certainly no thought of stuffing a boot with straw to make up for the loss of your foot. They would be celebrating in the Kremlin. That was the plan. That's what they thought. So listeners will remember from the last episode that Peter had seized part of the Baltic coast and he'd founded his new city of St. Petersburg amid the bogs and marshes. But all the momentum seemed to lie with the ultimate Scandinavian.|||当时根本没有人想到冻伤或缺少脚趾脚跟。当然更没有人想过在靴子里塞稻草来弥补脚部的缺失。他们本该在克里姆林宫里庆祝。这就是计划。他们当时就是这么想的。所以听众们会从上一集中记得，彼得已经占领了波罗的海沿岸的一部分，并在沼泽之中建立了他的新城市圣彼得堡。但所有的势头似乎都掌握在那位终极斯堪的纳维亚人手中。
I mean, surely he'd be played by Alexander Skarsgård, wouldn't he? Of course he would. Yeah. He would be hunting bears with a pitchfork. He'd be sleeping outside. Won't even wear a hat. If you remember from the last episode, he'd gone through Poland. He'd gone through Saxony.
I mean, surely he'd be played by Alexander Skarsgård, wouldn't he? Of course he would. Yeah. He would be hunting bears with a pitchfork. He'd be sleeping outside. Won't even wear a hat. If you remember from the last episode, he'd gone through Poland. He'd gone through Saxony.|||我的意思是，他肯定会由亚历山大·斯卡斯加德扮演吧？他当然会的。是的。他会用草叉猎熊。他会露宿野外。甚至连帽子都不戴。如果你还记得上一集的内容，他穿过了波兰。他穿过了萨克森。
He had deposed fox tossing champion Augustus the strong as king of Poland. And now he's decided to go east. August 1707. He's ordered this thousand mile march on Moscow to depose Peter the Great and redraw the map of Europe. However, as your reading from Gustav Piper suggests, things don't go according to plan. So let's get into exactly what went wrong. As soon as the Swedes crossed the border
He had deposed fox tossing champion Augustus the strong as king of Poland. And now he's decided to go east. August 1707. He's ordered this thousand mile march on Moscow to depose Peter the Great and redraw the map of Europe. However, as your reading from Gustav Piper suggests, things don't go according to plan. So let's get into exactly what went wrong. As soon as the Swedes crossed the border|||他废黜了抛狐狸大赛冠军“强力王”奥古斯都的波兰国王之位。现在他决定向东进发。1707年8月。他下令对莫斯科进行这千里行军，旨在废黜彼得大帝并重新绘制欧洲地图。然而，正如你朗读的古斯塔夫·派珀的回忆所暗示的那样，事情并没有按计划进行。那么让我们来深入探讨究竟哪里出了问题。瑞典人刚一越过边界……
from Silesia into Poland, they discovered that the Russians had been expecting him, so the Russians have moved into Poland themselves. Peter has sent in his Cossack and Kalmyk, their kind of Central Asian horsemen, into Western Poland. And there, there had been a preview of what would come in the rest of the campaign. So they had basically tried to turn the whole place into a desert. They'd burn the towns, they'd smash the bridges, they'd poison the wells. And does this come as a surprise to Charles or do you think he'd been expecting this? I think he'd been expecting a bit of it but the sheer scale of it, the
from Silesia into Poland, they discovered that the Russians had been expecting him, so the Russians have moved into Poland themselves. Peter has sent in his Cossack and Kalmyk, their kind of Central Asian horsemen, into Western Poland. And there, there had been a preview of what would come in the rest of the campaign. So they had basically tried to turn the whole place into a desert. They'd burn the towns, they'd smash the bridges, they'd poison the wells. And does this come as a surprise to Charles or do you think he'd been expecting this? I think he'd been expecting a bit of it but the sheer scale of it, the|||从西里西亚进入波兰，他们就发现俄国人一直在等着他，因此俄国人自己也进入了波兰。彼得将他的哥萨克人和卡尔梅克人——也就是那种中亚骑兵——派往了波兰西部。在那里，上演了未来整个战役的预演。因此，他们基本上试图将整个地方变成一片沙漠。他们烧毁城镇，砸毁桥梁，在水井里下毒。这会令查理感到意外吗？还是你觉得他早有预料？我想他多少预料到了一点，但其惊人的规模和……
ruthlessness of it is terrifying to the Swedes. Of course the Swedes are a long way from Sweden. I mean their supply lines are very stretched and I think they are probably taken aback a bit by just the absolute single-mindedness of it. But of course most people think that the Swedes are going to win. Even in Moscow most people think the Swedes are going to win. So we have reports, you know, letters and things from foreign diplomats in Moscow, an Austrian envoy. No one spoke of anything except for flight or death. The foreigners, not just in Moscow, but of all the neighboring towns, applied to their ministers for protection
ruthlessness of it is terrifying to the Swedes. Of course the Swedes are a long way from Sweden. I mean their supply lines are very stretched and I think they are probably taken aback a bit by just the absolute single-mindedness of it. But of course most people think that the Swedes are going to win. Even in Moscow most people think the Swedes are going to win. So we have reports, you know, letters and things from foreign diplomats in Moscow, an Austrian envoy. No one spoke of anything except for flight or death. The foreigners, not just in Moscow, but of all the neighboring towns, applied to their ministers for protection|||其冷酷无情让瑞典人感到恐惧。当然，瑞典人距离瑞典本土非常遥远。我是说，他们的补给线拉得很长，而且我认为他们可能对这种绝对的单一目标性感到有点措手不及。但当然，大多数人仍然认为瑞典人会赢。甚至在莫斯科，大多数人也认为瑞典人会赢。所以我们有当时的报告，你知道的，来自莫斯科外国外交官的信件之类，比如一位奥地利特使。除了逃跑或死亡，没人谈论其他任何事。不仅在莫斯科，所有邻近城镇的外国人也纷纷向他们的部长申请保护……
as they feared not only the harshness and rapacity of the Swedes, but also a general rising and massacre in Moscow where people are already embittered by the immeasurable increase of the taxes. So there you have a couple of previews of some of the issues in this series. So the terror of the Swedes,
as they feared not only the harshness and rapacity of the Swedes, but also a general rising and massacre in Moscow where people are already embittered by the immeasurable increase of the taxes. So there you have a couple of previews of some of the issues in this series. So the terror of the Swedes,|||因为他们不仅害怕瑞典人的严酷和贪婪，还害怕莫斯科会发生总起义和大屠杀，那里的民众已经因税收的无限期增加而苦不堪言。所以，这就为大家预告了本系列中的一些问题。瑞典人的恐怖之处在于……
who are famous for their rap, but also Peter has basically put Russia onto a total war footing. And that of course creates great tensions as we will see in the second half of this episode. So Peter is in Warsaw where when he hears the news that Charles is advancing, he's occupied Warsaw and he says to his generals, look, we're not going to fight them in Poland, Poland, very flat country going to fight them in Poland, Poland very flat country.
who are famous for their rap, but also Peter has basically put Russia onto a total war footing. And that of course creates great tensions as we will see in the second half of this episode. So Peter is in Warsaw where when he hears the news that Charles is advancing, he's occupied Warsaw and he says to his generals, look, we're not going to fight them in Poland, Poland, very flat country going to fight them in Poland, Poland very flat country.|||他们以掠夺闻名（译者注：原文为rap，此处应为rapine掠夺之意），而且彼得基本上让俄罗斯进入了全面战争状态。正如我们将在本集下半部分所看到的，这当然会产生巨大的紧张局势。所以彼得当时在华沙，当他听到查理正在推进的消息时，他占领了华沙，并对他的将军们说：听着，我们不在波兰与他们交战，波兰是个非常平坦的国家，要在波兰与他们交战……波兰是个非常平坦的国家。
The Swedes will probably smash us. We must withdraw east and they head back to what's now Belarus. And while they're doing that, his great friend, Alexander Menshikov, who's commanding his dragoons. So he's the guy who's very avaricious, who's risen from the streets. Risen from the streets, exactly. And the guy who introduced him to Catherine, now his wife. So Menchikoff will try to delay the Swedes at the river crossings on the river Vistula and the
The Swedes will probably smash us. We must withdraw east and they head back to what's now Belarus. And while they're doing that, his great friend, Alexander Menshikov, who's commanding his dragoons. So he's the guy who's very avaricious, who's risen from the streets. Risen from the streets, exactly. And the guy who introduced him to Catherine, now his wife. So Menchikoff will try to delay the Swedes at the river crossings on the river Vistula and the|||瑞典人可能会粉碎我们。我们必须向东撤退。于是他们撤回了现在的白俄罗斯。在他们这么做的时候，他的挚友亚历山大·缅什科夫正指挥着龙骑兵。他就是那个非常贪婪、从底层街头爬起来的人。从底层街头爬起来的，没错。也就是那个把叶卡捷琳娜（现为彼得的妻子）介绍给他的人。因此，缅什科夫将试图在维斯瓦河的渡口延缓瑞典人的进攻……
Neman. So the kind of the rivers which have already appeared in the rest of history, because we may remember that when we did Hitler's war on Poland, this is where the Poles hoped to withdraw in 1939. where the polls hoped to withdraw in 1939. Peter is very, very anxious at this point. If you think of Peter the Great as a man of sort of unflappable, formidable stoicism, that is quite wrong. Peter is very jittery. He's twitching. I mean, he's literally twitching.
Neman. So the kind of the rivers which have already appeared in the rest of history, because we may remember that when we did Hitler's war on Poland, this is where the polls hoped to withdraw in 1939. where the polls hoped to withdraw in 1939. Peter is very, very anxious at this point. If you think of Peter the Great as a man of sort of unflappable, formidable stoicism, that is quite wrong. Peter is very jittery. He's twitching. I mean, he's literally twitching.|||以及涅曼河。这些河流之前在《历史的其余部分》中已经出现过了，因为我们可能还记得，当我们讲述希特勒对波兰的战争时，这就是波兰人在1939年希望撤退到的地方。波兰人在1939年希望撤退到的地方。彼得此刻非常非常焦虑。如果你把彼得大帝视为那种泰然自若、令人敬畏的斯多葛主义者，那就大错特错了。彼得非常神经质。他在抽搐。我是说，他真的在抽搐。
He's literally twitching. He's facing all sorts of rebellions in the East and the South of Russia. He spends weeks in bed with fever. He seems depressed. What's worse for him, his greyhound has died and he has to send his greyhound, who's called Lizetka, back to Moscow and he orders that she be stuffed for him. I mean, that's something he's very into, isn't it, that he's picked up in Amsterdam, is watching how corpses can be either stuffed or preserved in the equivalent
He's literally twitching. He's facing all sorts of rebellions in the East and the South of Russia. He spends weeks in bed with fever. He seems depressed. What's worse for him, his greyhound has died and he has to send his greyhound, who's called Lizetka, back to Moscow and he orders that she be stuffed for him. I mean, that's something he's very into, isn't it, that he's picked up in Amsterdam, is watching how corpses can be either stuffed or preserved in the equivalent|||他真的在抽搐。他正面临着俄罗斯东部和南部的各种叛乱。他发烧卧床数周。他看起来很沮丧。对他来说更糟糕的是，他的灵缇犬死了，他不得不把那只名叫利泽特卡的灵缇犬送回莫斯科，并下令将其做成标本。我的意思是，这也是他非常热衷的一点，不是吗？这是他在阿姆斯特丹学到的，就是观察尸体如何被制作成标本或用类似……
of formaldehyde. Exactly. And I think he had he not bought a swordfish and some other creature in London. A crocodile I think. Yeah. So he's very into all this. And it probably is no coincidence that it's at this point in November 1707 that he marries that mistress that Menchikoff had introduced him to, Catherine, because he's clearly feeling emotionally very fraught and he's very
of formaldehyde. Exactly. And I think he had he not bought a swordfish and some other creature in London. A crocodile I think. Yeah. So he's very into all this. And it probably is no coincidence that it's at this point in November 1707 that he marries that mistress that Menchikoff had introduced him to, Catherine, because he's clearly feeling emotionally very fraught and he's very|||福尔马林的东西保存。没错。而且我想他在伦敦是不是还买过一条箭鱼和其他什么生物。我想是一条鳄鱼。是的。所以他非常迷恋这一切。而且在1707年11月这个时间点，他与缅什科夫介绍给他的情妇叶卡捷琳娜结婚，这可能绝非巧合，因为他显然在情感上感到非常焦虑，并且非常……
dependent on her at this point. So he goes back to Moscow for Christmas. And then on the 8th of January, 1708, he leaves to rejoin the army in the West. And he's on his way when he receives one of multiple bombshell messages that will be occurring during this episode. The Swedes are advancing much more quickly than anybody anticipated. This is the Swedes great trademark. They're incredibly aggressive and decisive and swift.
dependent on her at this point. So he goes back to Moscow for Christmas. And then on the 8th of January, 1708, he leaves to rejoin the army in the West. And he's on his way when he receives one of multiple bombshell messages that will be occurring during this episode. The Swedes are advancing much more quickly than anybody anticipated. This is the Swedes great trademark. They're incredibly aggressive and decisive and swift.|||在这个时候依赖她。所以他回莫斯科过圣诞节。然后，在1708年1月8日，他离开莫斯科，重新加入西部的军队。正当他在路上时，他收到了本集中将出现的多个重磅消息之一。瑞典人的推进速度比任何人预期的都要快得多。这是瑞典人的一大标志。他们极其具有进攻性、果断而且迅捷。
They have already crossed the river Vistula and they are heading towards the Eastern border of Poland. So a blitzkrieg. It is a bit of a blitzkrieg. So what has actually happened? Menshikov was meant to try and stop them on the Vistula near Warsaw. What had happened is they had completely skirted the Polish capital. They had crossed the Vistula further north and now they are heading through eastern Poland
They have already crossed the river Vistula and they are heading towards the Eastern border of Poland. So a blitzkrieg. It is a bit of a blitzkrieg. So what has actually happened? Menshikov was meant to try and stop them on the Vistula near Warsaw. What had happened is they had completely skirted the Polish capital. They had crossed the Vistula further north and now they are heading through eastern Poland|||他们已经穿过了维斯瓦河，正朝着波兰东部边境前进。所以这是一场闪击战。这确实有点像闪击战。那么实际发生了什么？缅什科夫本应试图在华沙附近的维斯瓦河阻挡他们。实际情况是，他们完全绕过了波兰首都。他们在更北的地方渡过了维斯瓦河，现在正穿过波兰东部……
towards the Missourian lakes and the Grand Duchy of Lithuania. Now we're in the winter 1707 1708. So why is he invading in winter? Why do they keep doing this? It's a thousand miles. I mean, you don't have much choice over the seasons, but also if you go through Poland in the winter, then by spring summer, you'll be in Moscow. That's his thinking, but it still seems mad.
towards the Missourian lakes and the Grand Duchy of Lithuania. Now we're in the winter 1707 1708. So why is he invading in winter? Why do they keep doing this? It's a thousand miles. I mean, you don't have much choice over the seasons, but also if you go through Poland in the winter, then by spring summer, you'll be in Moscow. That's his thinking, but it still seems mad.|||朝马祖里湖群和立陶宛大公国前进。现在我们正处于1707至1708年的冬季。那么他为什么要选择在冬天入侵？为什么他们总是一再这么做？这是一千英里的路程。我的意思是，你对季节的选择余地不大，但如果你在冬天穿过波兰，那么到了春夏之交，你就会到达莫斯科。这就是他的想法，但看起来仍然很疯狂。
You can't win with the Russian weather because later on in this episode, not only be very cold, it will also be punishingly hot. I mean, this is just fine. I think Tom, the window that you're looking for doesn't really exist of lovely moderate English style temperate weather. It does just strike me though, that Charles 12th Napoleon, Hitler, that they all launched their invasions kind of late. I think that's harsh on Charles the 12th.
You can't win with the Russian weather because later on in this episode, not only be very cold, it will also be punishingly hot. I mean, this is just fine. I think Tom, the window that you're looking for doesn't really exist of lovely moderate English style temperate weather. It does just strike me though, that Charles 12th Napoleon, Hitler, that they all launched their invasions kind of late. I think that's harsh on Charles the 12th.|||你无法靠俄罗斯的天气取胜，因为在本集后面，天气不仅会非常寒冷，还会酷热难耐。我是说，这倒也无所谓。汤姆，我认为你所期待的、那种宜人的温和英式温带天气的窗口期其实并不存在。不过我确实有一种感觉，查理十二世、拿破仑、希特勒，他们发动入侵的时间似乎都点偏晚。我觉得这对查理十二世有点苛求了。
Really? I do. I think he's harsh on Charles the 12th. Really? I do. I think he set off, as we'll see, he often goes into winter quarters and stops and then waits and then moves again when the spring comes. OK, I mean, this is a long process. Anyway, they're going through into Lithuania. It's all very boggy. It's kind of thick forests and stuff.
Really? I do. I think he's harsh on Charles the 12th. Really? I do. I think he set off, as we'll see, he often goes into winter quarters and stops and then waits and then moves again when the spring comes. OK, I mean, this is a long process. Anyway, they're going through into Lithuania. It's all very boggy. It's kind of thick forests and stuff.|||真的吗？我是这么觉得的。我觉得你对查理十二世太苛刻了。真的吗？我是这么觉得的。我认为他出发时——正如我们即将看到的——他经常进入冬季营地停下来休整，然后等待，等春天到来时再重新出发。好吧，我的意思是，这是一个漫长的过程。不管怎样，他们正在进入立陶宛。那里到处都是沼泽。到处是茂密的森林之类的地方。
And the Swedes are absolutely living up to their reputation. So when they go into a village and they say to the peasants, give us all your food. If the peasants don't do it, they will hang the peasants children in front of them. So that is, I mean, again, is very Operation Barbarossa. It's very Operation Barbarossa. Did you know that just before the outbreak of the Second World War, the Swedes sent Hitler a statue of Charles XII to mark his birthday? I did not know
And the Swedes are absolutely living up to their reputation. So when they go into a village and they say to the peasants, give us all your food. If the peasants don't do it, they will hang the peasants children in front of them. So that is, I mean, again, is very Operation Barbarossa. It's very Operation Barbarossa. Did you know that just before the outbreak of the Second World War, the Swedes sent Hitler a statue of Charles XII to mark his birthday? I did not know|||而瑞典人也完全不负他们的“盛名”。因此，当他们进入一个村庄并对农民说“把你们所有的食物交出来”时，如果农民照办，那还好；如果不照办，他们就会当着农民的面把他们的孩子吊死。所以，这——我的意思是，这再次非常符合“巴巴罗萨行动”的作风。这简直就是巴巴罗萨行动。你知道吗？就在第二次世界大战爆发前夕，瑞典人曾向希特勒赠送了一尊查理十二世的雕像来庆祝他的生日？我不知道……
that that's an amazing fact why did he not learn the appropriate lesson I don't know lessons of history yeah the lessons of history we always love a lesson of history don't we well actually we always say there aren't any lessons of history I think in this case we can say that they invade Russia in the winter would be yeah definitely a lesson all right so we're in January the end of January 1708 it made me so fast. They've already reached the Eastern frontier of the Grand Duchy of Lithuania.
that that's an amazing fact why did he not learn the appropriate lesson I don't know lessons of history yeah the lessons of history we always love a lesson of history don't we well actually we always say there aren't any lessons of history I think in this case we can say that they invade Russia in the winter would be yeah definitely a lesson all right so we're in January the end of January 1708 it made me so fast. They've already reached the Eastern frontier of the Grand Duchy of Lithuania.|||这真是一个惊人的事实！为什么他没有吸取相应的教训？我不知道。历史的教训，是的，我们总是热爱历史教训，不是吗？嗯，其实我们总是说历史没有任何教训，但我认为在这种情况下，可以说他们在冬天入侵俄罗斯绝对是一个教训。好了，我们现在来到1708年1月，1月下旬。他们的推进速度太快了。他们已经到达了立陶宛大公国的东部边境。
And this is the town of Grodno or Hrodna. This is called now on the river Neiman, which is now in Belarus. Charles's scouts go ahead and they say there are Russian troops moving into the town. We must seize the main bridge over the Neiman first. And Charles says, great, I'll do it. Cause remember from last time he is, you could say cocky, hubristic, but also possessed with a sense of, you know, God has chosen him, God has already decided when he'll die.
And this is the town of Grodno or Hrodna. This is called now on the river Neiman, which is now in Belarus. Charles's scouts go ahead and they say there are Russian troops moving into the town. We must seize the main bridge over the Neiman first. And Charles says, great, I'll do it. Cause remember from last time he is, you could say cocky, hubristic, but also possessed with a sense of, you know, God has chosen him, God has already decided when he'll die.|||这就是格罗德诺（Grodno或Hrodna）镇。它现在被称为涅曼河畔的城市，目前位于白俄罗斯境内。查理的侦察兵先行一步，回报说有俄军正在开进该镇。我们必须首先夺取涅曼河上的主桥。查理说：太好了，我去办。因为大家还记得上集提到的，他这个人，你可以说是自负、傲慢，但也拥有一种信念，即上帝选中了他，上帝已经决定了他什么时候会死。
So there's no point in him trying to avoid it. And he's a great one rather than sort of Nelsonian spirit of leading by example. I put myself in the thick of the action my men will follow. With about 700 Swedish cavalry, he advances on this bridge and he finds the Russian cavalry already there three times more Russians than there are Swedes. Is that going to put him off? No, of course not. He's the King of Sweden.
So there's no point in him trying to avoid it. And he's a great one rather than sort of Nelsonian spirit of leading by example. I put myself in the thick of the action my men will follow. With about 700 Swedish cavalry, he advances on this bridge and he finds the Russian cavalry already there three times more Russians than there are Swedes. Is that going to put him off? No, of course not. He's the King of Sweden.|||所以他试图躲避也没有意义。而且他有一种伟大之处，与其说是纳尔逊式的以身作则的精神——“我把自己置身于激战的核心，我的部下就会跟随”——不如说……他带着大约700名瑞典骑兵向这座桥推进，结果发现俄国骑兵已经在那里了，俄国人的数量是瑞典人的三倍还多。这会让他退缩吗？不，当然不会。他是瑞典国王。
It's a really Hollywood scene. He leads his horsemen down. The river is frozen. They cross the frozen river. Some of the othermen down the river is frozen. They cross the frozen river. Some of the other Swedes storm onto the bridge. The Russians are stunned. They didn't expect this. Charles is like slashing with his sword firing off shots with his pistol.
It's a really Hollywood scene. He leads his horsemen down. The river is frozen. They cross the frozen river. Some of the othermen down the river is frozen. They cross the frozen river. Some of the other Swedes storm onto the bridge. The Russians are stunned. They didn't expect this. Charles is like slashing with his sword firing off shots with his pistol.|||这真是一个好莱坞式的场景。他率领骑兵冲了下去。河水已经结冰。他们穿过结冰的河面。一些其他的瑞典骑兵也顺着河流冲向冰面。他们穿过了结冰的河面。其他一些瑞典人则冲上了桥梁。俄国人惊呆了。他们完全没有预料到这一点。查理挥舞着军刀劈砍，同时用手枪开火。
The Russians completely panic and start to fall back. There are loads more Russians inside the town, but they panic. Oh my God, the Swedes are coming and they evacuate to. And so presumably this is confirming Charles in his sense that the Russians are hopeless. Of course, the Russians are useless. Here's the thing. One of those Russians who runs away is Peter the Great. Wow.
The Russians completely panic and start to fall back. There are loads more Russians inside the town, but they panic. Oh my God, the Swedes are coming and they evacuate to. And so presumably this is confirming Charles in his sense that the Russians are hopeless. Of course, the Russians are useless. Here's the thing. One of those Russians who runs away is Peter the Great. Wow.|||俄国人彻底陷入恐慌，开始后撤。镇里还有大批俄国人，但他们慌了。天哪，瑞典人来了！于是他们撤退了。因此，这大概进一步坚定了查理的看法，即俄国人无可救药。当然，俄国人就是废物。关键是：其中一个逃跑的俄国人竟然是彼得大帝。哇。
He was in the town. And so Charles was actually within, I don't know, a few hundred yards possibly or mile or whatever of capturing Peter. Weirdly, like 700 Swedes and thousands and thousands of terrified Russians. I mean, this is just how this war is working, but Peter completely believes in Charles's reputation, the Swedes reputation. So he and his army are in full retreat behind the river. And that's brilliant for Charles. He's managed to cross the Lithuanian border.
He was in the town. And so Charles was actually within, I don't know, a few hundred yards possibly or mile or whatever of capturing Peter. Weirdly, like 700 Swedes and thousands and thousands of terrified Russians. I mean, this is just how this war is working, but Peter completely believes in Charles's reputation, the Swedes reputation. So he and his army are in full retreat behind the river. And that's brilliant for Charles. He's managed to cross the Lithuanian border.|||他当时就在镇里。所以查理实际上距离俘虏彼得只有几百码甚至一英里左右的距离。奇怪的是，大约700名瑞典人和成千上万吓坏了的俄国人……我的意思是，这场战争就是这样进行的，但彼得对查理和瑞典人的名声深信不疑。因此，他和他的军队在河后全面撤退。这对查理来说太棒了。他成功地越过了立陶宛边境。
So he now puts his troops into winter quarters. It's the end of January and he says, right now we stop. Now we rest. We wait for the end of the winter. So Tommy, he is heeding your, your words about the Russian winter. Are the Russians attacking him? Are they kind of picking off foragers and that kind of thing? Well, they're in winter quarters too.
So he now puts his troops into winter quarters. It's the end of January and he says, right now we stop. Now we rest. We wait for the end of the winter. So Tommy, he is heeding your, your words about the Russian winter. Are the Russians attacking him? Are they kind of picking off foragers and that kind of thing? Well, they're in winter quarters too.|||于是他现在将军队安排进冬季营地。当时是一月底，他说：好啦，现在我们停下。现在我们休整。我们等待冬天的结束。所以，汤姆，他正在听取你关于俄罗斯冬天的忠告。俄国人在进攻他吗？他们会袭击零星的粮秣搜寻队之类吗？嗯，他们也在冬季营地里呢。
See, it's so cold. Charles has already covered almost 600 miles. So he's halfway to Moscow and he's really barely been challenged. Now being in winter quarters is not a great laugh. They all get dysentery, but Charles is very, very optimistic. He says to his men, I want you to prepare the maps now for the second leg. And that's the journey all the way to Moscow. And his quartermaster says to him him it is yet far hence to Moscow
See, it's so cold. Charles has already covered almost 600 miles. So he's halfway to Moscow and he's really barely been challenged. Now being in winter quarters is not a great laugh. They all get dysentery, but Charles is very, very optimistic. He says to his men, I want you to prepare the maps now for the second leg. And that's the journey all the way to Moscow. And his quartermaster says to him him it is yet far hence to Moscow|||你看，天气太冷了。查理已经行进了将近600英里。所以他已经走了一半去莫斯科的路，而且几乎没有遇到什么挑战。当然，待在冬季营地里可不是什么好玩的事。他们全都得了痢疾，但查理非常非常乐观。他对部下说：我要你们现在为第二阶段的行程准备地图。那是通往莫斯科的全部旅程。他的军需官对他说：距离莫斯科还很遥远呢……
and Charles says and I quote when we will begin to march again we shall get there never fear and actually across Europe at this point everybody thinks Charles will get there so Queen Anne's government in London which up to this point has still been recognizing Augustus the strong as the true king of Poland now says, no, no, it's obvious that Augustus and Peter are finished. And so who do they recognize as King Dominic? Our old friend Stanislaw Fleszczynski famous for his very easily pronounceable name. Do you know, I could honestly hear you say that all day.
and Charles says and I quote when we will begin to march again we shall get there never fear and actually across Europe at this point everybody thinks Charles will get there so Queen Anne's government in London which up to this point has still been recognizing Augustus the strong as the true king of Poland now says, no, no, it's obvious that Augustus and Peter are finished. And so who do they recognize as King Dominic? Our old friend Stanislaw Fleszczynski famous for his very easily pronounceable name. Do you know, I could honestly hear you say that all day.|||查理说（我引述原话）：“当我们再次开始进军时，我们就会到达那里，别害怕。”事实上，此时整个欧洲的每个人都认为查理会到达那里。因此，伦敦的安妮女王政府——直到此时仍承认“强力王”奥古斯都为波兰真正的国王——现在改口说：不，不，很明显奥古斯都和彼得都完蛋了。那么他们承认谁为国王呢，多米尼克？我们老朋友斯坦尼斯瓦夫·莱什琴斯基（Stanislaw Fleszczynski），以他那个极其容易发音的名字而闻名。你知道吗，老实说我可以听你一整天都在念这个名字。
Love it. Say it again. Stanislaw Fleszczynski. That's a strange fetish that you have Tom, but I applaud it. So Peter is doing exactly as you would expect him to. He tells his men what it calls a belt of total destruction, a hundred miles wide along all routes heading north, south or east from the Swedish camp. Every village must be burned.
Love it. Say it again. Stanislaw Fleszczynski. That's a strange fetish that you have Tom, but I applaud it. So Peter is doing exactly as you would expect him to. He tells his men what it calls a belt of total destruction, a hundred miles wide along all routes heading north, south or east from the Swedish camp. Every village must be burned.|||太棒了。再念一遍。斯坦尼斯瓦夫·莱什琴斯基。汤姆，你这真是一个奇怪的癖好，但我为你鼓掌。所以彼得正在做你意料之中的事。他命令部下在从瑞典营地向北、向南或向东的所有路线上，建立一个宽达一百英里的所谓“彻底毁灭带”。每个村庄都必须烧毁。
Every single scrap of food or fodder removed. I want the land to be a desert for the Swedes. He is assailed by the same doubts as everybody else. Peter comes down with a terrible fever in the early months of 1708. He has to miss the Easter services because he's so ill. And he says to his friends, you know, I'm so exhausted, I'm so tired, I'm so anxious, all of this.
Every single scrap of food or fodder removed. I want the land to be a desert for the Swedes. He is assailed by the same doubts as everybody else. Peter comes down with a terrible fever in the early months of 1708. He has to miss the Easter services because he's so ill. And he says to his friends, you know, I'm so exhausted, I'm so tired, I'm so anxious, all of this.|||每一片食物或草料都必须清除。我要让这片土地对瑞典人来说变成一片荒漠。他同样受到了和其他人一样的怀疑的困扰。在1708年初，彼得染上了可怕的高烧。他因为病得太重而不得不缺席复活节礼拜。他对朋友们说：你知道的，我太累了，我太疲惫了，我太焦虑了，诸如此类。
So the summer comes and now on the 9th of June, Charles orders his men to continue the march. Now his main force is about 35,000 men, which you might say is not that big. But if you heard the last episode, listeners will remember that there was a second Swedish force going to come down from Riga. Yeah. Up in the North, right? Exactly. Which has got a massive supply chain from Sweden. So they have thought about this and this is under a guy called count Lueven helped.
So the summer comes and now on the 9th of June, Charles orders his men to continue the march. Now his main force is about 35,000 men, which you might say is not that big. But if you heard the last episode, listeners will remember that there was a second Swedish force going to come down from Riga. Yeah. Up in the North, right? Exactly. Which has got a massive supply chain from Sweden. So they have thought about this and this is under a guy called count Lueven helped.|||于是夏天到了，在6月9日，查理下令部下继续行军。现在他的主力部队大约有35,000人，你可能会说这规模不算太大。但如果你听了上一集，听众们会记得还有第二支瑞典军队将从里加南下。是的。在北方，对吧？没错。它拥有来自瑞典的庞大补给线。所以他们考虑过这一点，这支军队由一个叫勒文豪夫（Löwenhaupt）伯爵的人率领。
And these two armies are going to rendezvous before the advance on Moscow. Now, Peter has many more men, more than a hundred thousand, but they're really spread out across the front. And everybody knows the Swedes have a track record of beating armies much larger than themselves. You know, the odds are you could say more or less even. So Charles sets out to the beginning of June. His men cross the river Berezina and they are now heading towards Smolensk, Western
And these two armies are going to rendezvous before the advance on Moscow. Now, Peter has many more men, more than a hundred thousand, but they're really spread out across the front. And everybody knows the Swedes have a track record of beating armies much larger than themselves. You know, the odds are you could say more or less even. So Charles sets out to the beginning of June. His men cross the river Berezina and they are now heading towards Smolensk, Western|||这两支军队将在向莫斯科推进之前会合。现在，彼得拥有更多的人马，超过十万人，但他们实际上分散在整个战线上。而且大家都知道，瑞典人有着击败远超自身规模军队的战绩。你知道，胜率可以说基本上不相上下。因此，查理在6月初出发。他的部下渡过了别列津纳河，现在正朝俄罗斯西部的斯摩棱斯克前进。
Russia. And then they turn South. It's pouring with rain. They are trudging through a sea of mud. And of course they don't have much food. They're still waiting to meet up with the second army. And at the end of the month, they meet a Russian army at a place called Holovchin, which is now in Belarus.
Russia. And then they turn South. It's pouring with rain. They are trudging through a sea of mud. And of course they don't have much food. They're still waiting to meet up with the second army. And at the end of the month, they meet a Russian army at a place called Holovchin, which is now in Belarus.|||俄罗斯。然后他们转向南方。当时正下着倾盆大雨。他们在泥泞的海洋中艰难跋涉。当然他们也没有多少食物。他们仍在等待与第二支军队会合。在该月底，他们在如今位于白俄罗斯境内一个叫霍洛夫钦（Holovchin）的地方遭遇了一支俄军。
Just, you're just hitting out the park. I'm just doing it for the name because there are yet more WC zed why I mean honestly, yeah, so impressive Dominic so they meet at this place Holofchin and Once again the Swedes win It's a sort of all guns blazing frontal assault on the Russian line his men wading across the river Blasting with their muskets, the Russians falling back soon after dawn, yet again a win for Charles in his win column. However there is a difference this time. This is really the first time that the Russians
Just, you're just hitting out the park. I'm just doing it for the name because there are yet more WC zed why I mean honestly, yeah, so impressive Dominic so they meet at this place Holofchin and Once again the Swedes win It's a sort of all guns blazing frontal assault on the Russian line his men wading across the river Blasting with their muskets, the Russians falling back soon after dawn, yet again a win for Charles in his win column. However there is a difference this time. This is really the first time that the Russians|||天哪，你简直太厉害了。我念这个名字纯粹是因为里面有更多难缠的字母组合，说实话，太令人印象深刻了，多米尼克！他们在霍洛夫钦这个地方相遇了。瑞典人再次获胜。这是一次对俄军防线的全火力正面进攻，他的部下涉水过河，用滑膛枪齐射，俄国人在拂晓后不久便开始后退，查理的胜绩榜上再次添了一场胜利。然而这次有所不同。这实际上是俄国人……
retreat in really good order, they don't panic, they don't throw their guns away, they don't run, it's all very calm and considered. And the thing is with each of these battles, even though the Russians are kind of retreating each time and they are always losing more men than the Swedes, but they can replace those men. There are no more Swedes once Charles has lost his men. So in this one, the Russians lost 1600 men, the Swedes 1250. But the Russians can easily find another 1600 men.
retreat in really good order, they don't panic, they don't throw their guns away, they don't run, it's all very calm and considered. And the thing is with each of these battles, even though the Russians are kind of retreating each time and they are always losing more men than the Swedes, but they can replace those men. There are no more Swedes once Charles has lost his men. So in this one, the Russians lost 1600 men, the Swedes 1250. But the Russians can easily find another 1600 men.|||第一次以非常良好的秩序撤退，他们没有惊慌失措，没有丢下武器，也没有逃跑，一切都非常冷静且有条不紊。问题在于，在每一次这样的战斗中，尽管俄国人每次都在撤退，并且他们阵亡的人数总是比瑞典人多，但他们能够补充这些兵员。而一旦查理失去了部下，就没有更多的瑞典人可以补充了。所以在这一战中，俄国人损失了1600人，瑞典人损失了1250人。但俄国人可以轻而易举地找到另外1600人。
The Swedes can't find 1250. And that is presumably, it's not just because they are in the depths of Russia, but also because the reserves of manpower back in Sweden are flat. Exactly. The reserves of manpower are pretty much exhausted as we will see, I think, in next week's episode. In Sweden, people are so desperate to avoid now serving the army.
The Swedes can't find 1250. And that is presumably, it's not just because they are in the depths of Russia, but also because the reserves of manpower back in Sweden are flat. Exactly. The reserves of manpower are pretty much exhausted as we will see, I think, in next week's episode. In Sweden, people are so desperate to avoid now serving the army.|||而瑞典人却找不到1250人。这大概不仅仅是因为他们身处俄罗斯腹地，也是因为瑞典本土的人力资源已经见底了。没错。正如我们将在下周的节目中所看到的，人力资源基本上已经耗尽了。在瑞典，人们为了逃避服兵役已经到了不择手段的地步。
I mean, they're left with really the dregs and they are all taken to the forest or cutting off fingers or shooting themselves in the leg or something in order to avoid going because I mean, no one wants to go and campaign to Russia. So at a place called Mokylev, which was later the headquarters of Nicholas II in the Great War. Charles stops. He has reached the River Dnieper, which is the border, the historic border of Russia proper.
I mean, they're left with really the dregs and they are all taken to the forest or cutting off fingers or shooting themselves in the leg or something in order to avoid going because I mean, no one wants to go and campaign to Russia. So at a place called Mokylev, which was later the headquarters of Nicholas II in the Great War. Charles stops. He has reached the River Dnieper, which is the border, the historic border of Russia proper.|||我的意思是，他们剩下的真的只有残渣余孽了，所有人都逃到森林里，或者砍断手指、朝自己的腿开枪之类的，以此来逃避参军，因为没有人愿意去俄罗斯远征。因此，在一个叫莫吉廖夫（Mokylev）的地方——后来这里在第一次世界大战中成为了尼古拉二世的总部——查理停了下来。他来到了第聂伯河畔，这是俄罗斯本土的边界、历史上的边界。
And here he stops on the Western bank and he waits because this is where he's going to rendezvous with Count Leuvenhaupt and the Baltic army with all the ammunition and the food and the supplies for Army with all the ammunition and the food and the supplies for the attack on Moscow and it's here that Charles's plan really starts to go wrong. So Leuvenhout, the guy who was commanding the Baltic Army, is a very very dutiful serious slightly melancholy man. Charles called him, he called him the little Latin Colonel. I thought he was's German yeah but he calls him Latin I think because they like he reads a lot of Latin oh I see not because he's like an Italian no I don't think he's a I
And here he stops on the Western bank and he waits because this is where he's going to rendezvous with Count Leuvenhaupt and the Baltic army with all the ammunition and the food and the supplies for Army with all the ammunition and the food and the supplies for the attack on Moscow and it's here that Charles's plan really starts to go wrong. So Leuvenhout, the guy who was commanding the Baltic Army, is a very very dutiful serious slightly melancholy man. Charles called him, he called him the little Latin Colonel. I thought he was's German yeah but he calls him Latin I think because they like he reads a lot of Latin oh I see not because he's like an Italian no I don't think he's a I|||在这里，他在西岸停了下来并开始等待，因为他将在这里与勒文豪夫伯爵以及波罗的海军队会合，后者携带着进攻莫斯科所需的全部弹药、食物和补给。正是在这里，查理的计划真正开始出现偏差。指挥波罗的海军队的勒文豪夫是一个非常尽职、严肃且略带忧郁的人。查理称他为“小拉丁上校”。我以为他是德国人呢。是的，但他叫他“拉丁”，我想是因为他读了很多拉丁文书籍。哦，原来如此，不是因为他像个意大利人。不，我认为他不是个……
don't use a valuable and doing excessive gesturing or anything like that I think quite the opposite actually I think he's very reserved and love and haps is the kind of man who will follow his orders to the absolute letter you know in the face of the most overwhelming danger, but he's not great at thinking for himself and using his own initiative. Now he had set off from Riga late. It had taken him ages to get these 2,000 wagons of supplies together. He's got about 12,000 men and he's made very, very slow progress through Latvia and Lithuania. Again, the problem is the weather.
don't use a valuable and doing excessive gesturing or anything like that I think quite the opposite actually I think he's very reserved and love and haps is the kind of man who will follow his orders to the absolute letter you know in the face of the most overwhelming danger, but he's not great at thinking for himself and using his own initiative. Now he had set off from Riga late. It had taken him ages to get these 2,000 wagons of supplies together. He's got about 12,000 men and he's made very, very slow progress through Latvia and Lithuania. Again, the problem is the weather.|||不是那种动作夸张或手势过多的人。恰恰相反，我认为他非常内敛。勒文豪夫是那种会绝对严格执行命令的人，即使面对压倒性的危险也是如此，但他不太擅长独立思考和发挥主观能动性。当时他从里加出发的时间就很晚。他花了很长时间才把这2000辆满载物资的马车凑齐。他大约有12,000人，在穿过拉脱维亚和立陶宛的途中进展非常非常缓慢。问题依然是天气。
It's pouring with rain. The terrain is so wet and muddy that these wagons are always getting stuck, and his men are having to effectively build makeshift roads of timber for the wagons to roll over them as they go through these marshes and whatnot. Charles waits and waits for Lüinhapt in Mogilev. He waits for a month. Then he waits for another month.
It's pouring with rain. The terrain is so wet and muddy that these wagons are always getting stuck, and his men are having to effectively build makeshift roads of timber for the wagons to roll over them as they go through these marshes and whatnot. Charles waits and waits for Lüinhapt in Mogilev. He waits for a month. Then he waits for another month.|||下着倾盆大雨。地形极其湿滑泥泞，这些马车总是陷入泥潭，他的士兵不得不临时用木头铺设简易道路，好让马车在穿过这些沼泽时能够碾过去。查理在莫吉廖夫苦等勒文豪夫。他等了一个月。接着又等了一个月。
It's now in the middle of August and there was still no sign of this Baltic relief column. His men are getting very restless and their horses are run out of fodder, out of food. So now he thinks, okay, I won't wait any longer. I'm just going to press on and this guy can catch up with me later. Okay, I won't wait any longer. I'm just going to press on and this guy can catch up with me later. So he crosses the Dnieper and by the 11th of September, he is just 50 miles outside Smolensk, but they really don't have any food at this point. And the mercenaries he is hired from Germany are very, very unhappy.
It's now in the middle of August and there was still no sign of this Baltic relief column. His men are getting very restless and their horses are run out of fodder, out of food. So now he thinks, okay, I won't wait any longer. I'm just going to press on and this guy can catch up with me later. Okay, I won't wait any longer. I'm just going to press on and this guy can catch up with me later. So he crosses the Dnieper and by the 11th of September, he is just 50 miles outside Smolensk, but they really don't have any food at this point. And the mercenaries he is hired from Germany are very, very unhappy.|||现在已经是八月中旬了，这支波罗的海救援纵队仍然毫无踪影。他的部下变得非常不安，马匹的草料和食物也已经耗尽。于是他想：好吧，我不再等了。我决定继续前进，这家伙以后可以追上我。好吧，我不再等了。我决定继续前进，这家伙以后可以追上我。于是他渡过了第聂伯河，到9月11日时，他距离斯摩棱斯克仅有50英里，但此时他们确实没有任何食物了。他从德国雇佣的雇佣兵也感到非常非常不满。
You know, we've signed up for this. This, we thought this was going to be a great campaign. And we're just incredibly hungry. Everywhere they look there's a huge pool of black smoke over the fields. The fields are burning so thick it was said that it blotted out the sun and at night in the darkness they can see the red glow of the countryside burning all the way to Slemenz because of course Peter's men have set it alight. So now Charles faces a fateful decision. He could go back to the river, to the Dnieper, to the rendezvous point and wait for Luevenhaupt. Or change direction. Instead of continuing towards Slemensk and then Moscow, he could turn south towards a Russian province called Severia, which is on the border of
You know, we've signed up for this. This, we thought this was going to be a great campaign. And we're just incredibly hungry. Everywhere they look there's a huge pool of black smoke over the fields. The fields are burning so thick it was said that it blotted out the sun and at night in the darkness they can see the red glow of the countryside burning all the way to Slemenz because of course Peter's men have set it alight. So now Charles faces a fateful decision. He could go back to the river, to the Dnieper, to the rendezvous point and wait for Luevenhaupt. Or change direction. Instead of continuing towards Slemensk and then Moscow, he could turn south towards a Russian province called Severia, which is on the border of|||你知道的，我们是来参加这个的。我们本以为这将是一场伟大的战役。而我们现在却饿得要命。放眼望去，田野上空弥漫着滚滚黑烟。田野燃烧得如此浓烈，据说遮蔽了太阳；到了夜色中，他们可以看到乡村燃烧的红光一直蔓延到斯摩棱斯克，因为彼得的部下当然已经把它们点燃了。因此，查理现在面临着一个重大的决定。他可以回到河边，回到第聂伯河的会合点去等待勒文豪夫；或者改变方向。他可以不再继续向斯摩棱斯克和莫斯科进发，而是向南转向一个名为瑟维里亚（Severia）的俄罗斯省份，该省位于……
modern-day Ukraine. Now why would he do that? The answer, because the fields there haven't been burned. So they could rest in this area, they could get the food they need, and then perhaps they could turn back towards the road to Moscow. And Charles is a gambler. He hates going back. He hates retreating.
modern-day Ukraine. Now why would he do that? The answer, because the fields there haven't been burned. So they could rest in this area, they could get the food they need, and then perhaps they could turn back towards the road to Moscow. And Charles is a gambler. He hates going back. He hates retreating.|||现代乌克兰的边界。他为什么要这么做？答案是：那里的田野没有被烧毁。因此他们可以在这个地区休整，获取所需的食物，然后或许可以重新转向通往莫斯科的道路。查理是个赌徒。他讨厌回头。他讨厌撤退。
So it's pretty obvious which he's going to pick. He's never going to go back to the river, to the rendezvous point. He's going to say to his man, yeah, why not? Why not head south towards Ukraine? We can find food there. And you know, we're kind of going slightly off piste and off track, but they're a long way from Sweden. We have a lot further away from Sweden, but we're only kind of going the wrong
So it's pretty obvious which he's going to pick. He's never going to go back to the river, to the rendezvous point. He's going to say to his man, yeah, why not? Why not head south towards Ukraine? We can find food there. And you know, we're kind of going slightly off piste and off track, but they're a long way from Sweden. We have a lot further away from Sweden, but we're only kind of going the wrong|||所以他会选择哪一个显而易见。他绝不会回到河边的会合点。他会对部下说：好吧，为什么不呢？为什么不向南前往乌克兰呢？我们在那里可以找到食物。你知道的，我们虽然有点偏离原定路线和轨道，但他们离瑞典很远。我们距离瑞典更远了，但我们只是有点走错了……
way so that we can go the right way later. That's kind of his thinking. So it is on the 15th of September, he says to his men, we break camp, we head south towards Ukraine. This will, by the way, will be the single most disastrous decision of his life. Because three days later, Löwenhaupt does reach the rendezvous point on the Znieper. And when he gets there, there's no sign of the king, but there are messengers who say to him, the king has changed his plans. He wants you to press on south as quickly as possible. But of course, Lelvenhaupt and his guys are totally exhausted.
way so that we can go the right way later. That's kind of his thinking. So it is on the 15th of September, he says to his men, we break camp, we head south towards Ukraine. This will, by the way, will be the single most disastrous decision of his life. Because three days later, Löwenhaupt does reach the rendezvous point on the Znieper. And when he gets there, there's no sign of the king, but there are messengers who say to him, the king has changed his plans. He wants you to press on south as quickly as possible. But of course, Lelvenhaupt and his guys are totally exhausted.|||方向，以便以后能走对方向。这就是他的想法。因此，在9月15日，他对部下说：我们拔营起寨，向南前往乌克兰。顺便说一句，这将是他一生中最灾难性的决定。因为三天后，勒文豪夫确实到达了第聂伯河上的会合点。当他到达那里时，不见国王的踪影，只有信使对他说：国王已经改变了计划。他要你尽快向南推进。但当然，勒文豪夫和他的部下已经精疲力竭了。
They've been trudging through all this mud for months. So they start very miserably to head across the river and to head south and then to his horror his scouts report they can see Russian cavalry on the horizon so the Russians are coming and what's obviously happened is Peter who up to this point has never been a great military tactician you know he hasn't actually been one of the great commanders of history by any means but he has spotted this gap between the two Swedish armies and he said, let's let Charles go to Ukraine. We'll deal with this Baltic relief column.
They've been trudging through all this mud for months. So they start very miserably to head across the river and to head south and then to his horror his scouts report they can see Russian cavalry on the horizon so the Russians are coming and what's obviously happened is Peter who up to this point has never been a great military tactician you know he hasn't actually been one of the great commanders of history by any means but he has spotted this gap between the two Swedish armies and he said, let's let Charles go to Ukraine. We'll deal with this Baltic relief column.|||他们几个月来一直在泥地里艰难跋涉。于是他们极其悲惨地开始渡河向南进发，随后令他惊恐的是，侦察兵报告说在地平线上看到了俄国骑兵——俄国人来了。显然发生的情况是：彼得——在此时之前从未算得上什么伟大的军事战术家，你知道的，他绝不是历史上那些伟大的统帅之一——却发现了这两支瑞典军队之间的空隙，并说道：让查理去乌克兰吧。我们来收拾这支波罗的海救援纵队。
Let's hoover this up. He's actually adopting Charles's tactics. Yeah, I guess so. Target one of your enemies and leave the other and then. Yes, target the weaker one, deal with that and then exactly. So by the 28th of September, Lovv Lovenhaupt has been cornered by Peter near a village called Les Nyer with his back to the river. The numbers are roughly equal.
Let's hoover this up. He's actually adopting Charles's tactics. Yeah, I guess so. Target one of your enemies and leave the other and then. Yes, target the weaker one, deal with that and then exactly. So by the 28th of September, Lovv Lovenhaupt has been cornered by Peter near a village called Les Nyer with his back to the river. The numbers are roughly equal.|||把他们吃掉。他实际上采用了查理的战术。是的，我想是的。集中打击一个敌人，留下另一个，然后……是的，瞄准较弱的一个，解决掉他，然后……没错。因此，到9月28日，勒文豪夫在莱斯纳亚（Les Nyer）村附近被彼得逼入绝境，背水一战。双方兵力大致相当。
The Swedes are exhausted though, after this ridiculous march through all this mud. Peter orders the attack around midday. It lasts all afternoon. It's a horribly kind of attritional, muddy, bloody, miserable encounter. The Swedes, of course, because they're so good, even though they're exhausted, they equip themselves pretty well. And so as night falls and the snow starts falling inevitably, the honours are roughly even. And in fact, the snowstorm is so fierce they can't continue. The Russians fall back a bit and now Lovenhout has a choice to make and he says to his men,
The Swedes are exhausted though, after this ridiculous march through all this mud. Peter orders the attack around midday. It lasts all afternoon. It's a horribly kind of attritional, muddy, bloody, miserable encounter. The Swedes, of course, because they're so good, even though they're exhausted, they equip themselves pretty well. And so as night falls and the snow starts falling inevitably, the honours are roughly even. And in fact, the snowstorm is so fierce they can't continue. The Russians fall back a bit and now Lovenhout has a choice to make and he says to his men,|||不过瑞典人经过了这场荒谬的泥泞行军后已经精疲力竭。彼得在中午左右下令进攻。战斗持续了整个下午。这是一场极其消耗、泥泞、血腥而悲惨的遭遇战。瑞典人当然因为军事素质过硬，尽管精疲力竭，表现得依然相当不错。因此，随着夜幕降临和大雪不可避免地开始飘落，双方大致打成平手。事实上，暴风雪如此猛烈，以至于他们无法继续战斗。俄国人稍微退后了一点，现在勒文豪夫面临着一个选择，他对部下说：
look we can't stay here, we're absolutely shattered. I can't face a second day of this. Our priority must be to head on south and catch up with the king and that means we can't take this supply train with us. The thing they've been escorting all this way. He says we just have to destroy it, we don't want it to fall into enemy hands. These cannons that they have been dragging for hundreds of miles, they lift them out of the wagons and they bury them underground and then they set fire to the wagons. This doesn't seem a display of master strategy.
look we can't stay here, we're absolutely shattered. I can't face a second day of this. Our priority must be to head on south and catch up with the king and that means we can't take this supply train with us. The thing they've been escorting all this way. He says we just have to destroy it, we don't want it to fall into enemy hands. These cannons that they have been dragging for hundreds of miles, they lift them out of the wagons and they bury them underground and then they set fire to the wagons. This doesn't seem a display of master strategy.|||听着，我们不能留在这里，我们彻底崩溃了。我无法面对第二天的战斗。我们的首要任务必须是继续向南赶上国王，这意味着我们不能把这支补给纵队带在身边。这是他们一路护送的东西。他说我们只能摧毁它，我们不想让它落入敌人手中。这些他们拖了数百英里的加农炮，被从马车上抬下来埋在地下，然后他们放火烧毁了马车。这看起来不像是大师级的战略展现。
Well no I suppose it isn't. What else could he do though? The supply train is really slowing him down. I suppose he could stand and fight for a second day. Yeah. But his men are so tired that he thinks, you know, that we're really risking disaster then. Okay, so maybe I'm being harsh on him. You're not Tom, because actually what then happens is a complete and utter catastrophe. And the Swedes behave in a very un-Scandinavian way, I would say. So they've set their own wagons on fire.
Well no I suppose it isn't. What else could he do though? The supply train is really slowing him down. I suppose he could stand and fight for a second day. Yeah. But his men are so tired that he thinks, you know, that we're really risking disaster then. Okay, so maybe I'm being harsh on him. You're not Tom, because actually what then happens is a complete and utter catastrophe. And the Swedes behave in a very un-Scandinavian way, I would say. So they've set their own wagons on fire.|||嗯，不，我想确实不是。但他还能怎么做呢？补给纵队确实大大拖慢了他的速度。我想他可以坚持打第二天。是的。但他的部下太累了，以至于他认为，你知道的，那样做我们真的会有招致灾难的风险。好吧，也许我对要求太苛刻了。你没有，汤姆，因为实际上接下来发生的是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。而且瑞典人的表现可以说是非常不符合斯堪的纳维亚人的风格。他们竟然放火烧了自己的马车。
And in the darkness, some of the soldiers decide they will loot the wagons of their officers and they get stuck into their brandy. They're all tanked up on brandy, which goes straight to their heads because they're so tired. Discipline completely falls apart. Some of the Swedes say, let's just run for it. And they run off into the forest. Some of them even to say, we're doomed, let's just run for it. And they run off into the forest. Some of them even to say, we're doomed,
And in the darkness, some of the soldiers decide they will loot the wagons of their officers and they get stuck into their brandy. They're all tanked up on brandy, which goes straight to their heads because they're so tired. Discipline completely falls apart. Some of the Swedes say, let's just run for it. And they run off into the forest. Some of them even to say, we're doomed, let's just run for it. And they run off into the forest. Some of them even to say, we're doomed,|||在黑暗中，一些士兵决定去抢劫他们军官的马车，并贪婪地喝起了白兰地。由于过度疲劳，白兰地直冲他们的脑门，他们都喝得酩酊大醉。纪律彻底崩溃了。一些瑞典人说：“我们逃跑吧。”于是他们逃进了森林。有些人甚至说：“我们死定了，我们逃跑吧。”于是他们逃进了森林。有些人甚至说：“我们死定了……
let's desert to the Russians. And the army begins to fragment. And in the darkness, Cossack horsemen kind of come out of the woods and set upon little kind of groups of the Swedish book staggering drunkenly around. And by dawn, as dawn breaks, Lovenhout has just about managed to restore order among
let's desert to the Russians. And the army begins to fragment. And in the darkness, Cossack horsemen kind of come out of the woods and set upon little kind of groups of the Swedish book staggering drunkenly around. And by dawn, as dawn breaks, Lovenhout has just about managed to restore order among|||向俄国人投降吧。”军队开始解体。在黑暗中，哥萨克骑兵从树林里冲出来，袭击了一小群一小群醉醺醺、步履蹒跚的瑞典士兵。到了拂晓时分，当黎明到来时，勒文豪夫总算勉强恢复了部队的秩序……
his troops. But in the chaos of about 12,000 men, he has lost perhaps 6,000 overnight. He's either wandered into the snow, they've drowned, they've been picked off by the Cossacks. Is this what inspires the Swedes to make alcohol so expensive? Almost certainly. They learnt the lesson. Almost certainly. I hadn't thought of that, but yeah, they have learnt the lesson. So he's lost everything.
his troops. But in the chaos of about 12,000 men, he has lost perhaps 6,000 overnight. He's either wandered into the snow, they've drowned, they've been picked off by the Cossacks. Is this what inspires the Swedes to make alcohol so expensive? Almost certainly. They learnt the lesson. Almost certainly. I hadn't thought of that, but yeah, they have learnt the lesson. So he's lost everything.|||但在大约12,000人的混乱中，他可能在一夜之间损失了6,000人。他们要么迷失在雪地里，要么淹死了，要么被哥萨克人消灭了。这就是启发瑞典人把酒卖得如此昂贵的原因吗？几乎可以肯定。他们吸取了教训。几乎可以肯定。我之前没想过这一点，但确实，他们吸取了教训。所以他失去了一切。
He's lost all the clothing, the uniforms, the gunpowder, the muskets, the medicines, the cannons on which Charles was counting, a total and utter catastrophe. He manages to get the 6,000 men away and they stagger South towards Charles's camp in Severia, where they arrive 10 days later. And you can imagine Charles's face falling when he sees them. Like where are all the wagons? But can you, I actually imagine his face not falling. Yeah, you're probably right.
He's lost all the clothing, the uniforms, the gunpowder, the muskets, the medicines, the cannons on which Charles was counting, a total and utter catastrophe. He manages to get the 6,000 men away and they stagger South towards Charles's camp in Severia, where they arrive 10 days later. And you can imagine Charles's face falling when he sees them. Like where are all the wagons? But can you, I actually imagine his face not falling. Yeah, you're probably right.|||他失去了所有的衣服、制服、火药、滑膛枪、药品以及查理寄予厚望的加农炮，这是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。他设法带领剩下的6,000人撤离，他们步履蹒跚地向南朝着查理在瑟维里亚的营地走去，并在10天后抵达。你可以想象当查理看到他们时，脸一下子沉了下来。就像在问：马车都在哪儿呢？但你可以吗？我其实想象他的脸并没有沉下来。是的，你可能是对的。
He would preserve his, his mask of Sanfroid, but inside there'd be a little, maybe a little twitch of his, his mouth. Or maybe he would give her kind of cold half smile as he realized. Like Svane Fortbeard. Yeah. A cold half smile as he realized that God had set him a tougher challenge than ever, but he would never doubt that it was a challenge he was bound to pass. He would sort of say, well, this will make the reports of my ultimate victory even more glowing. Yeah. And that we've done it without all these supplies. Meanwhile, Peter is delighted. Yeah. Effectively
He would preserve his, his mask of Sanfroid, but inside there'd be a little, maybe a little twitch of his, his mouth. Or maybe he would give her kind of cold half smile as he realized. Like Svane Fortbeard. Yeah. A cold half smile as he realized that God had set him a tougher challenge than ever, but he would never doubt that it was a challenge he was bound to pass. He would sort of say, well, this will make the reports of my ultimate victory even more glowing. Yeah. And that we've done it without all these supplies. Meanwhile, Peter is delighted. Yeah. Effectively|||他会保持自己那副镇定自若的面具，但内心深处可能会有那么一点、也许是嘴角的一丝抽搐。或者当他意识到时，他会报以一种冰冷的半笑。就像“胡须叉”斯韦恩（Svane Fortbeard）。是的。当他意识到上帝为他设置了比以往更严峻的挑战时，他流露出一丝冰冷的微笑，但他从不怀疑这是他注定要通关的挑战。他大概会说：“好吧，这会让关于我最终胜利的报告更加光芒四射。”是的。“而且我们是在没有任何补供应的情况完成这一切的。”与此同时，彼得欣喜若狂。是的。实际上……
he's knocked one of these two Swedish armies out. So Peter goes and holds a triumph. He has a triumphant Smolensk. Well, it's the third Rome, isn't it? Why not? Yeah. He forces Swedish prisoners to march to the streets with their flags. He has, it's the first time really, I think that he does this and it really imprints itself in the European imagination. He has battle descriptions and plans of the battle of Lesnaya printed in Russian and in Dutch, make sure they're sent to people all over Europe because he, you know, he wants to win the publicity war, I guess.
he's knocked one of these two Swedish armies out. So Peter goes and holds a triumph. He has a triumphant Smolensk. Well, it's the third Rome, isn't why not? Yeah. He forces Swedish prisoners to march to the streets with their flags. He has, it's the first time really, I think that he does this and it really imprints itself in the European imagination. He has battle descriptions and plans of the battle of Lesnaya printed in Russian and in Dutch, make sure they're sent to people all over Europe because he, you know, he wants to win the publicity war, I guess.|||他已经击溃了这两支瑞典军队中的一支。于是彼得去举行了一场凯旋仪式。他在斯摩棱斯克举行了凯旋。好吧，这里是第三罗马，为什么不呢？是的。他强迫瑞典战俘举着旗帜游街示众。这真的是他第一次这么做，我认为这在欧洲人的想象中留下了深刻的印记。他将莱斯纳亚战役的战况描述和作战计划用俄语和荷兰语印刷出来，确保它们被送到全欧洲的人手里，因为他，你知道的，他想要赢得宣传战，我猜。
Of course. There's more good news for Peter. There was a third Swedish army advancing from the Baltic, which we haven't talked about at all, which was going to try and attack St. Petersburg, but they ran out of food and they were treated before they even got anywhere near St. Petersburg. So Peter is thrilled.
Of course. There's more good news for Peter. There was a third Swedish army advancing from the Baltic, which we haven't talked about at all, which was going to try and attack St. Petersburg, but they ran out of food and they were treated before they even got anywhere near St. Petersburg. So Peter is thrilled.|||当然。对彼得来说还有更多好消息。还有一支从波罗的海推进的第三支瑞典军队，我们之前根本没有谈到过，它原本试图进攻圣彼得堡，但他们的食物耗尽了，甚至在还没接近圣彼得堡之前就撤退了。所以彼得欣喜若狂。
Like suddenly, you know, for the first time in this entire campaign, he really has the upper hand and against all the odds I think he can sense that he's going to win this and then on the 27th of October 1708 he gets a message from his friend Alexander Menshikov and this really is a bombshell because Charles has broken camp and he is marching very swiftly into Ukraine. So South away from Moscow and Sweden away from Moscow, but he's heading into the heart of Ukraine. Why? Because a man called Ivan Mazepa, the Hetman of the Zaporozhian host and
Like suddenly, you know, for the first time in this entire campaign, he really has the upper hand and against all the odds I think he can sense that he's going to win this and then on the 27th of October 1708 he gets a message from his friend Alexander Menshikov and this really is a bombshell because Charles has broken camp and he is marching very swiftly into Ukraine. So South away from Moscow and Sweden away from Moscow, but he's heading into the heart of Ukraine. Why? Because a man called Ivan Mazepa, the Hetman of the Zaporozhian host and|||就像突然之间，你知道的，在这场战役的整个过程中，他第一次真正占了上风，而且在重重困难面前，他能感觉到自己会赢得这场战争。然后，在1708年10月27日，他收到了他的朋友亚历山大·缅什科夫发来的消息，这真是一个重磅炸弹，因为查理已经拔营起寨，正以极快的速度向乌克兰挺进。所以是向南远离莫斯科和瑞典、远离莫斯科，但他正在直奔乌克兰的心脏地带。为什么？因为一个名叫伊万·马泽帕（Ivan Mazepa）的人——扎波罗热哥萨克的盖特曼（统帅）——以及……
leader of the Ukrainian Cossacks, previously loyal to Peter has changed sides. After 20 years, he has abandoned the Tsar of Russia, he has thrown in his lot with the Swedes and with that the balance of the war has tipped back towards Charles XII. Goodness Dominic, another staggering twist and we will take a break now to cope with the excitement of this moment and when we come And we will take a break now to cope with the excitement of this moment. And when we come back, we will be continuing with the Great Northern War. Hi, this is Cathy Kaye from The Rest Is Politics US. And this is Anthony Scaramucci.
乌克兰哥萨克的领袖、此前效忠于彼得的人倒戈了。在20年之后，他背叛了俄罗斯沙皇，投靠了瑞典人，随着这一变故，战争的天平再次倾向了查理十二世。天哪，多米尼克，又是一个令人震惊的转折，我们现在要休息一下，平复一下此刻激动的心情，当我们回——我们现在要休息一下，平复一下此刻激动的心情。而当我们回来时，我们将继续讲述大北方战争。嗨，我是来自《真相即政治：美国版》的凯茜·凯伊。我是安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇。
I've spent over two decades reporting from Washington. Presidents, while they come and go, the chaos, that never changes. And I've been inside the eye of the storm, 11 wild days in Trump's White House. I have seen how the sausage gets made and who's holding the knife. Yeah, that's not a nice image. But on the rest is politics, US.
我花了两二十多年的时间在华盛顿进行报道。总统们来了又去，但混乱从未改变。我曾身处风暴眼之中，经历了特朗普白宫里疯狂的11天。我见证了香肠是如何制造出来的，以及谁手里拿着刀。好吧，这个比喻不太美妙。但在《真相即政治：美国版》中。
We break down the stories that are behind the headlines and we actually look at what they mean to America and the rest of the world as well. We're not just talking politics, we're talking about power. We've got both of us, access, experience, and just enough cynicism to know when something smells a little off and how to trace it back to the source.
我们剖析头条新闻背后的故事，并且真正去探讨它们对美国以及世界其他地方意味着什么。我们不只是在谈论政治，我们在谈论权力。我们两个都具备这种资源、经验，以及恰到好处的犬儒主义，能够察觉出哪里不对劲，并顺藤摸瓜找到根源。
No spin, no filter, reporting the stories you won't hear anywhere else. If you want smart analysis, global context, and a front row seat to the world's loudest democracy, this is the show. It's from two people that have ringside seats, occasionally center stage, in a country where court cases and campaign rallies share the same parking lot. The rest is politics, US. New episodes every week.
没有空话，没有滤镜，只报道你在其他地方听不到的故事。如果你想要聪明的分析、全球视野，并想获得旁听世界最喧嚣民主政治的第一排座位，这就是属于你的节目。这是由两个拥有最佳席位、偶尔甚至能登上舞台中央的人带给你的，在一个诉讼和竞选集会共用同一个停车场的国家。这就是《真相即政治：美国版》。每周都有新单集。
Hello, welcome back to the rest is history. Charles the 12th is marching southwards and he is marching towards a country that has of course been in the news a great deal recently. And that is Ukraine. And Dominic, if there's one thing that people know about the history of Ukraine, it's unbelievably complicated, isn't it? It is complicated. So, uh, Ukrainian history in the 17th century, one-on-one.
哈喽，欢迎回到《历史的真相》。查理十二世正一路向南进发，他正朝着一个最近当然经常登上新闻头条的国家前进。那就是乌克兰。多米尼克，如果说人们对乌克兰历史有什么了解的话，那就是它 unbelievably 复杂，对吧？确实很复杂。所以，呃，17世纪的乌克兰历史，基础入门。
So most of modern Ukraine had been part of the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth for centuries. And you can divide its population incredibly roughly and simplistically into four groups. There's a Polish landowning elite in Ukraine, Polish speaking. There are millions of what were then called Ruthenian peasants. So these are the people that will become Ukrainians. In the towns in particular, there is a Jewish population. It's a great place for kind of Jewish settlements and Jewish culture.
现代乌克兰的大部分地区几个世纪以来一直是波兰-立陶宛联邦的一部分。你可以极其粗略和简单地把其人口分为四类。乌克兰有一个波兰地主精英阶层，说波兰语。有数百万当时被称为鲁塞尼亚人的农民。这些人就是后来将成为乌克兰人的人。特别是在城镇里，有一个犹太人社群。这里是犹太人定居点和犹太文化的绝佳场所。
And there are lots and lots of kind of runaways, fugitives, freebooters, outlaws and adventurers. The people of what you might call the Wild East. And these were originally called Kazakhs or indeed Cossacks. These people have carved out their own kind of slightly semi-nomadic existence on the steppes of Ukraine. Because these are the old stamping grounds of the Scythians, isn't it? Yes, that's right. So it's very suited to horse-born raiders and all that. Exactly, who have their own kind of traditions and they've sort of developed their real mix
还有大量形形色色的逃亡者、逃犯、自由抢劫犯、法外之徒和冒险家。也就是你可能会称之为荒蛮东部的人。这些人最初被称为哈萨克人或实则是哥萨克人。这些人通过自己的方式在乌克兰大草原上开辟了一种半游牧的生活存在。因为这里是斯基泰人的老根据地，对吧？是的，没错。所以它非常适合骑马劫掠者之类的人。完全正确，他们有着自己独特的传统，并且他们某种程度上发展出了一种真正的融合
of kind of ruffians and ne'er-do-wells and exiles and whatnot. And over time, over the decades and the centuries, they have developed their own traditions, their own distinctive identity as Cossacks. They love a furry hat. They do love a furry hat. They also love a rebellion and a very bloody rebellion at that. So in 1648, Tom, I'm sure you remember when we did the episodes on Ukraine many, many years ago, the story of Bogdan Chmielnicki.
由流氓、无赖、流放犯等组成。随着时间的推移，经过几十个世纪的发展，他们发展出了自己的传统，作为哥萨克人自己鲜明的身份认同。他们喜欢毛茸茸的帽子。他们确实很喜欢毛茸茸的帽子。他们还喜欢叛乱，而且是一场非常血腥的叛乱。所以在1648年，汤姆，我确信你还记得我们很多很多年前做关于乌克兰的单集时，博格丹·赫梅利尼茨基的故事。
Of course I do. It's never out of my mind. At his rebellion against his Polish overlords, the Cossacks had revolted. They had carried out the most hideous massacres of Jews and pogroms and stuff. And they'd revolted against the Poles and they had appealed to Moscow to Muscovy for help and so this had led to the formation of a kind of Cossack military state in central Ukraine which was called the Zaporozhian host or the Zaporozhian Hetmanate and this was a vassal of the Russian Tsar and this is where Charles is now heading towards the separation head minute and the reason he's doing this is because he's been driven out of severe the province of russia where he was last.
我当然记得。它从未离开过我的脑海。在他反抗波兰统治者的叛乱中，哥萨克人起义了。他们对犹太人进行了最可怕的大屠杀和集体迫害等等。他们反抗波兰人，并向莫斯科、向莫斯科公国寻求帮助，于是这导致了在乌克兰中部建立了一种哥萨克军事国家，被称为扎波罗热军或扎波罗热酋长国，这是俄罗斯沙皇的附庸，而这正是查理现在正前往的方向——分离的酋长国，他之所以这么做，是因为他被驱逐出了俄罗斯的瑟韦里亚省，他之前就在那里。
Because the russian army is now advancing very quickly you crane has what he needs it has fertile land that is not been burned and has loads of food. our land that has not been burned and has loads of food. And it has this new ally, this new factor in the Game of Thrones, who is the Hetman of the Cossacks, Ivan Mazepa. Somebody about whom Lord Byron writes. He did a brilliant poem. And we might come on to what exactly Byron is writing about in due course, because Mazepa supposedly has quite an active adolescence doesn't he? He does, yeah we definitely come on to that. So Mazepa, this is very George RR Martin like and then we're throwing in yet another colourful character. Mazepa had been born in a place
因为俄军现在的推进速度非常快，乌克兰拥有他所需要的东西：它有未被烧毁的肥沃土地，并且有大量的食物。肥沃的土地，没有被烧毁，而且有大量的食物。它还有这个新的盟友，这个权力游戏中的新变数，那就是哥萨克酋长伊万·马泽帕。拜伦勋爵曾为他写过书。他写了一首精彩的诗。我们或许会在适的时候讨论拜伦具体写了什么，因为马泽帕据说有着相当活跃的青春期，对吧？是的，确实如此，我们绝对会谈到这一点。所以马泽帕，这非常像乔治·R·R·马丁的小说，然后我们又加入了另一个色彩斑斓的角色。马泽帕出生在一个地方
called Podolia which is in the sort of south west of Ukraine now towards the Moldovan Romanian border and it was then part when he was born in 1645 at the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth. He came from an Orthodox Ruthenian, that's to say Ukrainian family, but his parents sent him to Catholic schools and a Jesuit academy and he learned Polish as well as Russian and Latin. So actually all these Latin speakers, I mean him and Charles, they'll chat away in Latin. Yeah. Here's our answer to that internal Restless History Club question.
名叫波多利亚，它现在位于乌克兰西南部左右，靠近摩尔多瓦和罗马尼亚边境，当他在1645年出生时，那里是波兰-立陶宛联邦的一部分。他来自一个正教会的鲁塞尼亚家庭，也就是乌克兰家庭，但他的父母把他送到天主教学校和耶稣会学院学习，他学会了波兰语以及俄语和拉丁语。所以实际上所有这些说拉丁语的人，我是说他和查理，他们可以用拉丁语闲聊。是的。这就是我们对那个内部“历史的真相”俱乐部的回答。
Who would you like to invite to a dinner party? I'd invite Charles the 12th, Peter the Great, this guy Mazepa and they could all talk in Latin and Augustus the Strong tossing foxes in the background. Peter doesn't speak Latin, does he? He does speak Dutch. That's right. That's right. But I speak neither Dutch nor Latin.
你想邀请谁来晚宴？我会邀请查理十二世、彼得大帝、这家伙马泽帕，他们全都可以用拉丁语交谈，而奥古斯特二世则在背景里抛着狐狸。彼得不会说拉丁语，对吧？他会说荷兰语。没错。没错。但我既不会说荷兰语也不会说拉丁语。
So, well, you could just serve the drinks. Yeah, exactly. Oh, no, you don't want to be serving the drinks at one of Peter the Great's dinner parties, because then he brings out the bellows and you're in real trouble. You could handle the bears. Exactly. So anyway, this guy, Mazepa, the Cossack, his father got him a job as a page at the Polish court and he became a sort of junior diplomatic official.
好吧，那你就可以只负责端饮料。对，没错。哦，不，你可不想在彼得大帝的晚宴上端饮料，因为接下来他会掏出风箱，那你可就大难临头了。你能对付那些熊。完全正确。所以不管怎样，这家伙，马泽帕，这个哥萨克人，他的父亲给他找了一份在波兰宫廷当侍童的工作，他成了一种初级外交官。
He did old jobs for the Polish king in Ukraine. But now we come to the story Tom that I imagine you're thinking of, which is that supposedly when he was living on a country estate in northern Ukraine, he got into trouble for seducing a landowner's wife and the landowner and his mate stripped this guy Mazepa naked. They tarred and feathered him. They tied him to a horse and then they set this horse loose. Yeah. Galloping through the woods and through thorny thickets.
他为波兰国王在乌克兰干过老差事。但现在我们来到了汤姆我想你正在想的故事，据说当他在乌克兰北部的一个乡村庄园生活时，他因为诱惑了一个地主的妻子而惹上了麻烦，地主和他的朋友把这个叫马泽帕的家伙扒了个精光。他们给他涂上柏油并粘上羽毛。他们把他绑在一匹马身上，然后把这匹马放生了。是的。在树林里和荆棘丛中狂奔。
When he finally got home, he was so scratched and bloodied and battered that he was almost unrecognizable. And, uh, Byron writes a poem about that and his journey on the back of the horse is emblematic of the romantic spirit. Yeah. Crashing across the steps. And you know what? This never happened at all.
当他终于回到家时，他浑身是抓痕、血迹和伤痕，几乎让人认不出来。而且，呃，拜伦为此写了一首诗，他骑在马背上的旅程是浪漫主义精神的象征。是的。在草原上横冲直撞。你知道吗？这根本就没发生过。
I know, I know, but it's a great poem, nevertheless. OK, well, you're going to be quoting Lord Baron next week's episode, aren't you? Well, that is something people look forward to. Well, they can't wait. So many people desperate to join the rest of this history club, just so they can hear that right now. Anyway, this guy, Mersepe, he ends up working as a diplomat for the Cossacks.
我知道，我知道，但尽管如此，这依然是一首好诗。好吧，你下周的单集里肯定会引用拜伦勋爵的话，对吧？好吧，那是人们非常期待的事情。好吧，他们已经迫不及待了。有那么多的人迫不及待地想要加入“历史的真相”俱乐部，只为了现在就能听到这个。不管怎样，这家伙，马泽帕，他最终成了哥萨克的职业外交官。
He travels around very widely. He goes to Russia, he goes to the Ottoman Empire and in 1687. So when he's in his early forties, the Russians pick him as the new Cossack Hetman, the new leader of the Cossacks. It's a great job, isn't it? To be a Cossack Hetman. A brilliant job. Now today in Russia, Mosea is one of the great villains
他到处游历。他去过俄罗斯，去过奥斯曼帝国，并且在1687年。当他四十出头时，俄罗斯人选他为新的哥萨克酋长，哥萨克的新领袖。这份工作很棒，对吧？做一名哥萨克酋长。一份绝佳的工作。如今在俄罗斯，马泽帕是历史上的一大恶人
of history. You know, he really does rank among the sort of Benedict Arnold. Right, like a Benedict Arnold figure because he betrays them and joins Charles the 12th. But as with Benedict Arnold, yeah, in fact, he's a bit of a hero. Yeah, well, Benedict Arnold, certainly, he was a patriot and he was true to his loyal king. I mean, when I say a Patriot, he was a patriotic British American. Yep. We very much approve of that. But, um, Mazepa is not a sort of slimy villainous, he's not like little finger from game of Thrones or something.
之一。你知道，他确实可以跟阿诺德这样的人物相提并论。没错，就像一个本笃·阿诺德式的人物，因为他背叛了他们并加入了查理十二世。但正如本笃·阿诺德一样，是的，事实上，他有点像个英雄。好吧，本笃·阿诺德当然曾经是个爱国者，他忠于他效忠的国王。我的意思是，当我说他是个爱国者时，他是一个爱国的不列颠裔美国人。没错。我们非常赞同这一点。但是，呃，马泽帕不是那种油腔滑调的恶棍，他不像《权力的游戏》里的贝里席或者什么人。
He's fun. Isn't he? He's bright. He's charming. He's ambitious, but he's very good at politics. Now he's been the Cossack Hetman for 13 years. He's approaching 60 years old and he's been playing this very complicated political and very tricky and dangerous political game because what he reminds
他很有趣，不是吗？他很聪明。他很有魅力，有野心，但他非常擅长政治。现在他已经当了13年的哥萨克酋长了。他快60岁了，一直在玩一场非常复杂、非常棘手且危险的政治游戏，因为他让我想起
me of are the people who are the kind of Russian client leaders today in that sort of Chechnya or Belarus or whatever. Oh, all those people with the enormous orange beards. Right. Those kinds of guys. He's a person who has to basically ride two horses. He has to keep him in Moscow You know, he can never alienate the government in Moscow
的是如今在车臣或白俄罗斯等地充当俄罗斯傀儡领袖的那些人。哦，所有那些留着巨大橙色胡须的人。没错。就是那种人。他是一个基本上必须骑两匹马的人。他必须维系莫斯科的关系你知道，他绝不能疏远莫斯科政府
But at the same time he has to show to his people that he's not just Moscow's puppets that actually, you know He's a very proud patriot and he's getting stuff out of Moscow that no one else could get you know, and he's got to sort of please these two constituencies, I suppose and And he's got to sort of please these two constituencies, I suppose. And his independence therefore is very important to him. So although he is dependent on Moscow to some degree, he has to appear autonomous. That really matters to the Cossacks in particular because their frontier spirit, I don't want to degenerate into Cossack cliches, but their proud frontier wild spirits, that's really important to them.
但与此同时，他必须向他的人民表明，他不仅仅是莫斯科的傀儡，实际上，你知道的，他是一个非常骄傲的爱国者，他正在从莫斯科那里得到别人无法得到的东西，你知道的，他必须安抚这两个群体，我想，而且他必须安抚这两个群体，我想。因此，他的独立对他来说非常重要。所以尽管他在某种程度上依赖莫斯科，但他必须显得具有自主性。这对于哥萨克人来说尤为重要，因为他们的边境精神——我不想堕落为哥萨克人的陈词滥调，但他们骄傲的边境狂野精神，这对他们来说真的非常重要。
But they began as runaways, right? As adventurers and outlaws and stuff. So, Mazepa has always been, you know, he's always been in with Peter. In the great Sophia versus Peter stuff from the first week of this series, he'd been on Team Sophia for a long time, but the timed it perfectly. And they defected to Peter just before Peter. And so that's the kind of the marker of the political skills that you were talking about and which you need to survive in the predatory world of Russian politics. Exactly. So Peter thinks this guy Mazep is lovely. He's colorful, he's funny, he's very smart.
但他们最初是逃亡者，对吧？作为冒险家、法外之徒之类的人。所以，马泽帕一直以来，你知道，他一直和彼得混在一起。在这个系列的第一个星期里，关于索菲亚与彼得的宏大故事中，他长期以来都是索菲亚阵营的人，但他时机把握得极其完美。他们在彼得动手前不久向彼得倒戈了。所以这就是你刚才谈到的那种政治技巧的标志，这是在俄罗斯政治这个弱肉强食的世界中生存所必需的。完全正确。所以彼得觉得这个叫马泽帕的家伙很可爱。他色彩丰富，幽默风趣，非常聪明。
Whenever he came to Moscow, Peter gave him kind of honors. He gave him the Order St. Andrew, the thing that had been offered to the Duke of Marlborough. He gets Augustus the strong to give him the order of the white Eagle from Poland. So, you know, he festoons him with honors. The problem is that once you get into the war and the total war, the price of being dependent on Moscow is getting higher and higher because of course, Peter's demanding conscripts, his levying taxes on mustaches as well as wills and births and deaths. And I imagine that Mzeppa has a tremendous mustache.
每当他来到莫斯科，彼得都会授予他各种荣誉。他授予他圣安德鲁勋章，这个原本是要颁给马尔伯勒公爵的荣誉。他让奥古斯特二世授予他波兰的白鹰勋章。所以，你看，他用各种荣誉装点着他。问题是，一旦你卷入了战争和全面战争，依赖莫斯科的代价就会越来越高，因为当然，彼得正在要求征兵，他对胡须以及遗嘱、出生和死亡征税。而且我可以想象马泽帕有一撮极具气势的胡子。
The Cossacks pride themselves I imagine on their mustaches and their beards. Peter is constantly saying send me more laborers for St Petersburg, send me food for the army, all of this kind of thing, which creates great resentment among the Cossacks. And of course, Mzeppa doesn't want to be blamed. Right. Because they're a proud independent people. A proud independent people. What is more, they are a proud independent, orthodox people, and they are as alarmed as anybody, if not more so, at this talk of cutting people's caftans into trimming people's beards,
哥萨克人引以为豪，我想象他们为自己的胡须和络腮胡感到骄傲。彼得不断地要求“给我送更多的劳动力去圣彼得堡，给军队送食物”，诸如此类的事情，这在哥萨克人当中引起了极大的怨恨。当然，马泽帕可不想成为被怪罪的对象。没错。因为他们是一个骄傲独立的人民。一个骄傲独立的人民。不仅如此，他们是一个骄傲独立的东正教人民，他们和任何人一样，甚至更加警惕这种把人们的卡夫坦长袍剪短、修剪人们胡须的说法，
excessive shaving, Germanic ways. This stuff goes down really badly with the Cossacks. But I mean that doesn't necessarily mean that they will therefore side with a Lutheran invader, right? No, not at all. You know, there's a lot of clean shaven Swedes. I mean, they're all clean shaven I imagine. Exactly. Apart from what's his name? Benny. Benny from ABBA. He had a beard. Yeah.
过度刮胡子，日耳曼化的习俗。这些东西在哥萨克人那里非常不受欢迎。但我的意思是，这并不一定意味着他们就会因此站在一个路德教入侵者一边，对吧？不，完全不是。你知道，有很多刮得光溜溜的瑞典人。我是说，我想他们全都是刮得光溜溜的。完全正确。除了叫什么名字来着？本尼。来自ABBA的本尼。他留着胡子。是的。
I mean, this is a really niche and obscure reference, but Sweden's best player at the 1990 World Cup was man called Glenn Stromberg. He had a massive beard. And so did Bjerg Borg, the great tennis player. So actually it's not an absolute rule, is it? We should definitely do. When the rest of history has become really decadent We've run out of history on the Swedish beer History's greatest sweet
我是说，这是一个非常小众和晦涩的梗，但瑞典在1990年世界杯上最好的球员是一个叫格伦·斯特龙贝里的人。他留着一把巨大的胡子。伟大的网球运动员比约恩·博格也是。所以实际上这并不是一条绝对的规律，对吧？我们绝对应该做一期。当《历史的真相》变得真正颓废的时候，我们讲完了瑞典啤酒的历史，历史上最甜的
Yeah That's yeah, I Can't believe we're doing Chatham High Street and we're not doing that. That's deranged I mean Chatham High Street is an absolutely obvious topic, right? So to go back to what we were saying you're dead right that all of this wouldn't necessarily encourage you to rebel. I think what changes everything is the war and the course of the war, because by about 1706, when it looks like Charles is definitely going to win, Mzeppa has to start thinking, well, what do I do? You know, I've been loyal to Peter and Peter's vassal.
是的，那就是，是的，我真不敢相信我们正在做恰塔姆高街的节目却没有做那个，那太疯狂了。我是说，恰塔姆高街绝对是一个显而易见的话题，对吧？所以回到我们刚才所说的，你完全说得对，所有这些并不一定能鼓励你起义。我认为改变一切的是战争和战争的进程，因为大约在1706年，当看起来查理铁定会赢的时候，马泽帕不得不开始思考，好吧，我该怎么做？你知道的，我一直忠于彼得，而且是彼得的附庸。
He doesn't want to end and Peter's vassal. He doesn't want to end up like Augustus the strong. He doesn't want to end up being toppled and deposed by Stanislaw Fleshtyn. He definitely doesn't want that. I mean, I guess it's like the situation he faced with Sophia and, and Peter, you know, you've got to time your betrayal expertly, haven't you? Time your betrayal. And his dream, I think, is that if he times his betrayal just right, Charles will make him king in some way or make him prince or basically he'll be able
他不想落得像奥古斯特二世一样的下场。他不想被斯坦尼斯瓦夫·莱什琴斯基推翻和罢免。他绝对不想那样。我想这就像他当年面对索菲亚和彼得时的处境一样，你知道的，你必须极其精准地把握背叛的时机，对吧？把握背叛的时机。而他的梦想，我认为，如果他把背叛的时机把握得恰到好处，查理会以某种方式让他当国王或让他当亲王，或者基本上他将能够
to establish a hereditary Cossack monarchy and Mazepa and his dynasty. And Charles is not aiming to rule the Ukraine. No. So there's a serious prospect of him being given full independence, I guess. Yes, exactly right. And in the spring of 1708, so just at the point where we are in the story, Peter starts to get reports from another Cossack bigwig that Mazepa is talking to the Swedes in secret.
建立一个世袭的哥萨克君主国，由马泽帕和他的王朝统治。而查理的目标并不是统治乌克兰。没有。所以他获得完全独立的可能性很大，我猜。是的，完全正确。而在1708年春天，也就是我们故事进行到的这个时间点，彼得开始收到另一个哥萨克大人物的报告，称马泽帕正在私下与瑞典人接触。
Now, as it happens, the reason that this guy informs on Mazepa is that Mazepa has seduced his daughter, who's about, you know, 15 and Mazepa is 60 Mazepa has seduced his daughter who's about you know 15 and Mazepa is 60. So Peter discounts the rumours, he says well this guy's clearly just sour grapes because Mazepa's sleeping with this bloke's daughter and then Mazepa is able to have this guy beheaded. That's right, so that's worked out well for him. But not for the girl, I mean this is bad news for the girl right? What happens to the girl?
碰巧的是，这家伙向彼得举报马泽帕的原因是，马泽帕诱奸了他的女儿，女孩大约，你知道的，15岁，而马泽帕60岁了。马泽帕诱奸了他的女儿，女孩大约，你知道的，15岁，而马泽帕60岁了。所以彼得对这些谣言不屑一顾，他说，好吧，这家伙显然只是吃醋，因为马泽帕在和这家伙的女儿睡觉，然后马泽帕得以把这家伙给斩首了。没错，所以这对他的进展很顺利。但对那个女孩来说可不好，我是说这对女孩来说是个坏消息，对吧？那个女孩怎么样了？
Well her dad's just had his head cut off and she's a teenager and she's sleeping with a 60 year old man. Nothing good has happened to her. That could be worse. I mean, she could have been murdered. I suppose so. We don't know what it's like. You know what?
好吧，她爸爸刚被砍了头，而她还是个十几岁的少女，却在和一个60岁的男人睡觉。没有一件好事降临在她身上。这还算好的。我是说，她本来可能被谋杀了。我想也是。我们不知道那是什么样的经历。你知道吗？
Mazepa's company is like they do, we tell them. I mean, that might be a fate worse than death. He could tell her amusing stories of his youth being tied to horses. Can indeed. Now the irony is of course, at this point, the Mazepa does really decide to back Sweden after all. Dominic, how is he going to do this? Because I guess it's a very delicate process, isn't it, to portray someone like Peter the Great? It is, it is. You have to time it perfectly.
马泽帕的伴侣就像他们那样，我们告诉过他们。我的意思是，那可能是一个比死还难受的命运。他可以给她讲一些他年轻时被绑在马身上的有趣故事。确实可以。现在具有讽刺意味的是，当然，在这个时候，马泽帕确实决定最终支持瑞典。多米尼克，他要怎么做呢？因为我猜这是一个非常微妙的过程，对吧，要背叛像彼得大帝这样的人？确实如此，确实如此。你必须把时机把握得完美无缺。
Now all that summer 1708 as Charles is kind of faffing around further north, more and more rumors are reaching Peter that Mazepa is wobbling. And Mazepa is holed up in the Cossack stronghold at a place called Baturin. This is the great kind of, to the degree that the Cossacks have a capital, this is it, isn't it? Exactly, exactly. And I sort of imagine it being like this sort of Dothraki in Game of Thrones or something.
整个1708年那个夏天，当查理在更北方的地方磨磨蹭蹭时，越来越多的传言传到彼得耳中，说马泽帕动摇了。而马泽帕正躲在巴图林这个哥萨克重镇里。这是那种伟大的，如果哥萨克人有一个首都的话，那就是这里了，对吧？完全正确，完全正确。我脑海中想象它就像《权力的游戏》里的多斯拉克人营地或者类似的地方。
Of course you do. Yeah, obviously. And Peter summons Mazepa, come and explain yourself and explain what's going on. And Mazepa sends a series of excuses to say that he's ill and he can't come. And then eventually he goes to the extent of taking to his deathbed and getting a priest to give him the last rites. I mean, that's kind of like trying to get off P.E. taking it to a ridiculous extent. Exactly.
你当然会这么想。是的，很显然。彼得传唤马泽帕，来解释一下你自己在搞什么名堂，解释一下到底是怎么回事。马泽帕送去了一连串的借口，说他病了，来不了。然后他最终甚至到了卧床不起的地步，还找了个神甫来给他做临终祈祷。我的意思是，这有点像为了逃避体育课而把装病进行到了荒谬的程度。完全正确。
But then end of September 1708, yet more bombshell news. First of all, Charles is now heading straight for Baturin, hotly pursued by Russian armies. So the war is coming to Ukraine and the Cossacks are clearly going to have to pick a side. Yeah, because they've got no choice now. No choice. And secondly, Alexander Menshikov, Peter's great pal, is riding to Baturin himself with a party of Dragoons to see if Mazepa really is dying, bringing a thermometer, taking temperature, and to choose his successor when he does die. Right. He actually hates Menshikov already.
但随后在1708年9月底，又有更多重磅消息传出。首先，查理现在正径直朝着巴图林进发，俄军在后面紧追不舍。所以战争正在逼近乌克兰，哥萨克人显然必须选边站了。是的，因为他们现在别无选择。别无选择。其次，彼得的好哥们亚历山大·缅什科夫正带着一队龙骑兵亲自骑马赶往巴图林，去看看马泽帕是不是真的要死了，顺便带个体温计测量体温，并准备在他死后挑选他的继任者。没错。他其实已经恨透了缅什科夫了。
And he thinks, Oh no nightmare. So he summons his 2000 closest and most loyal retainers and they mount their horses and they ride out of Baturin for the Swedish camp to rendezvous with Charles. So when Menshikov finally arrives at the Cossack citadel with a small force of dragoons, he finds that Mazepa is long gone and he immediately reports to Peter, disaster, Mezeppa has deserted us and thrown in his lot with Charles XII. But he's only taken 2,000, he hasn't taken the rest of the Cossacks. He's only taken 2,000 exactly, he's then going to raise the rest of the Cossacks afterwards. So Peter acts very quickly and very decisively, he orders Menshikov and his dragoons to fan out
他心想，哦不，这简直是噩梦。于是他召集了他手下2000名最亲信、最忠诚的随从，他们骑上马，离开巴图林前往瑞典军营与查理会合。所以当缅什科夫带着一小队龙骑兵终于抵达哥萨克城堡时，他发现马泽帕早就逃之夭夭了，他立即向彼得报告：灾难发生了，马泽帕背叛了我们，投靠了查理十二世。但他只带走了2000人，并没有带走剩下的哥萨克人。他只带走了2000人，没错，他随后还要去动员剩下的哥萨克人。所以彼得行动非常迅速且果断，他命令缅什科夫和他的龙骑兵散开
across the countryside to prevent anybody joining Mzeppa. It does seem that Peter is getting the hang of war by this point. He is. Peter was really making a series of very good decisions now, like very smart decisions. You could argue it's easy to do that when circumstances are in your favour. But the Swedes are still a formidable adversary. I mean he's a guy who learns, doesn't he? Yes, absolutely.
到广袤的乡村去，以阻止任何人加入马泽帕。看起来彼得到这个时候已经逐渐掌握战争的诀窍了。是的。彼得现在确实做出了一系列非常好的决定，比如非常明智的决定。你可以争辩说，当形势对你有利时，这样做很容易。但瑞典人仍然是一个强大的对手。我是说他是一个懂得学习的人，对吧？是的，绝对的。
Well, we saw going around shipyards in Amsterdam and London. I mean, he's a man who enjoys learning things. Yes, and he's making good, decisive, very ruthless but effective decisions. So he issues a public proclamation to the people of Ukraine. And he says, Mzeppa is the new Judas. I mean, that's literally how he's described. He is defected in order to put the land of little Russia as before under the dominion of Poland and to turn the churches and monasteries over to the Catholics. Now the interesting thing about this, of course, is there's no mention of the Swedes or Lutheranism, but it's playing on the deep dislike that the kind of ordinary Ruthenian peasants and
嗯，我们看到他去参观阿姆斯特丹和伦敦的造船厂。我是说，他是一个喜欢学习新事物的人。是的，他正在做出良好、果断、极其冷酷但有效的决定。所以他向乌克兰人民发布了一份公开宣言。他说，马泽帕是新犹太。我的意思是，字面意思上他就是这么被描述的。他叛变是为了把小俄罗斯的土地像以前一样置于波兰的统治之下，并把教堂和修道院交给天主教徒。关于这一点，有趣的是，这里面当然完全没有提到瑞典人或路德宗，但它利用了普通鲁塞尼亚农民和
the Cossacks have for their former Polish overlords. Yeah, very cunning. So what's happening with Mazepa and Charles? Well the Swedes have been delighted to see Mazepa. They've been very excited to see him and of course Charles is delighted because he thinks well when we get to his citadel. Yeah, to Batcharin, Batcharin must be full of all kinds of supplies and goodies, which is what they need.
哥萨克人对他们以前的波兰统治者的深切厌恶。是的，非常狡猾。那么马泽帕和查理情况如何？嗯，瑞典人很高兴看到马泽帕。他们看到他非常兴奋，当然查理也很高兴，因为他心想，好吧，当我们到达他的城堡时。是的，去巴图林，巴图林一定囤满了各种物资和好东西，而这正是他们所需要的。
Supplies, gunpowder, fur hats. Shelter. Exactly. So by early November they have crossed the rivers into the steppes of central Ukraine and on the 11th of November Charles's scouts glimpse Batchurin on the horizon. So fire, food, welcome. But the closer they get, they see smoke rising overhead. Oh no. Because Baturin is burning. While Charles had been on his way, Alexander Menshikov's dragoons had stormed the Cossack capital.
补给、火药、毛皮帽子。庇护所。完全正确。所以在11月初，他们渡过了河流，进入了乌克兰中部的大草原，11月11日，查理的侦察兵在地平线上看到了巴图林。所以那里有火、食物和欢迎。但他们越靠近，就看到滚滚浓烟升腾而上。哦不。因为巴图林正在燃烧。就在查理赶来的途中，亚历山大·缅什科夫的龙骑兵已经攻占了哥萨克的首都。
They had slaughtered 6,000 men, women and children. They had destroyed all the Cossack supplies and they had burned the fortress to the ground. And then they'd held this public ceremony where they had officially stripped Mazepa of his title as the Hetman. They had dragged his portrait through the dust and then hanged it from the gallows beside the piles of butchered bodies. And then they got the Metropolitan of Kyiv, the sort of great churchmen, to read a sentence of excommunication and anathema against Mazepa. And amazingly, this was read out in Ukrainian churches every year until 1869, which is one reason I guess why his name endures in Russia and Ukraine is this kind of great character of history.
他们屠杀了6000名男性、女性和儿童。他们摧毁了所有的哥萨克物资，并将这座要塞烧成了平地。然后他们举行了一个公开仪式，正式剥夺了马泽帕的酋长头衔。他们把他的画像在尘土中拖行，然后将其悬挂在屠宰尸体堆旁的绞架上。接着他们找来了基辅都主教，那位伟大的教会神职人员，宣读了对马泽帕的绝罚令和诅咒。令人惊奇的是，乌克兰的教堂每年都会宣读这个判决，一直持续到1869年，我想这也是为什么他的名字在俄罗斯和乌克兰作为这样一个历史上的伟大角色而流传下来原因之一。
Of course, for the Russians, a great villain. Yeah. And now for Ukrainian nationalists, they see him as much more of a hero. I mean, what is clear is that Charles the 12th and Peter the great are two of history's great grudge holders. They are. I mean, they are Titanic in the grudges that they hold. Exactly.
当然，对俄罗斯人来说，他是个大反派。是的。而现在对乌克兰民族主义者来说，他们视他为更多的英雄。我的意思是，显而易见的是，查理十二世和彼得大帝是历史上最懂得记仇的两个人。他们确实是。我是说，他们记仇的程度简直是泰坦级的。完全正确。
But of course this changes the picture for the war. First of all it sends a very clear signal to all the other cossacks if you join Mzeppa and back Sweden then Peter's wrath will be terrible his retribution swift to quote the Lord of the Rings. It means that Charles isn't going to get the food and supplies that he needs and it kind of makes Mzeppa irrelevant now because he's just hanging around with Charles. But what can he bring Charles? He's no longer the leader of the Cossack. But surely also, I mean, on the geopolitics of the war, it also means that it's mad that Charles XII is in Ukraine when he's a Swede who's aiming to march on Moscow.
但当然，这改变了这场战争的全局。首先，它向所有其他哥萨克人发出清晰的信号：如果你加入马泽帕并支持瑞典，那么彼得的怒火将是可怕的，他的报复将是迅雷不及掩耳的，借用《指环王》里的话说。这意味着查理将无法获得他所需的食物和补给，这使得马泽帕现在变得无足轻重，因为他只是跟在查理身边晃悠。但他能给查理带来什么呢？他不再是哥萨克的领袖了。但当然，从战争的地缘政治来看，这也意味着查理十二世身在乌克兰是极其荒谬的，因为他明明是一个志在进军莫斯科的瑞典人。
I mean, he's now essentially completely the raw end of Europe. He is. He's gone massively out of his way. And with nothing to show for it. I mean, he's in this bigger hole as he ever was. A bigger one, perhaps. Exactly, because now the Russians are chasing him. They're blocking the roads to the north.
我的意思是，他现在基本上完全落入了欧洲最被动的边缘境地。他确实如此。他绕了一个极其巨大的远路。而且毫无成果。我的意思是，他陷入了比以往任何时候都更深的泥潭。可能是一个更大的泥潭。完全正确，因为现在俄罗斯人正在追击他。他们正在封锁通往北方的道路。
And as you say, he has no supplies. And now where are we? We're in Ukraine in November. Winter is coming. So now both sides hunker down for the winter. If you look at a map of Ukraine, the Swedes are in a place called Hadjach, which is roughly midway between Kiev and Kharkiv on today's map. The Russians are kind of blocking them in an arc to the north east stopping them from getting back up to was moskow. What are the both. You know on campaign in winter this is a lot better for peter is on home to rain is gonna lose a man power and he's got time on his side.
正如你所说，他没有补给。现在我们身在何处？我们在11月的乌克兰。冬天就要来了。所以现在双方都在猫冬准备过冬。如果你看一眼乌克兰的地图，瑞典人正身处一个叫加佳奇的地方，在今天的地图上，它大致位于基辅和哈尔科夫的正中间。俄罗斯人正以一个东北方向的弧形将他们封锁在那里，阻止他们重新打回莫斯科去。双方都在做什么呢？你知道，在冬天的战役中，这对彼得有利，他是在本土作战，而查理将失去兵力，并且时间站在他这边。
What's really crucial now is it's not just as it were the russian ukrainian winter it's a winter like no other. Ukrainian winter, it's a winter like no other. Because we talked about this a long time ago, one of our early episodes about how the weather changed history. This winter of 1708-1709 is the worst winter in Europe for 500 years. The Baltic, the Seine, the Thames, the canals of Venice, even the Atlantic harbours, they all freeze over. There are all these reports from all over Europe of farm animals freezing to death in the fields. In France alone, half a million people froze or starved to death.
现在真正至关重要的事情是，这不仅仅是所谓的俄乌之冬，这是一个前所未有的冬天。乌克兰的冬天，这是一个前所未有的冬天。因为我们在很久以前讨论过这个问题，在我们的早期单集之一中，谈到了天气是如何改变历史的。1708年至1709年的这个冬天是欧洲500年来最寒冷的冬天。波罗的海、塞纳河、泰晤士河、威尼斯运河，甚至大西洋的港口，全都结冰了。欧洲各地都有农场动物在田野里被冻死的报告。仅在法国就有50万人被冻死或饿死。
And Dominic, even more importantly, doesn't the wine in Versailles freeze? It does. Yeah, right, exactly. The wine in Versailles froze. The British economy shrunk by a quarter and didn't recover its value for years. And in the open steps of Ukraine where there is no respite from the kind of howling snowstorms, it is just awful. And this is what we began with, that reading.
而且多米尼克，更重要的是，凡尔赛宫里的酒难道没有结冰吗？确实结冰了。是的，没错，完全正确。凡尔赛宫的酒结冰了。英国经济缩水了四分之一，多年来价值都没有恢复。而在乌克兰开阔的大草原上，狂风呼啸的暴风雪无处可藏，情况简直糟糕透顶。这就是我们开篇时朗读的内容。
So this is where the bloke loses his foot to frostbite. A Lutheran pastor who was with the Swedish army wrote afterwards, the spittle from people's mouths turned to ice before hitting the ground. Sparrows fell frozen from the roofs to the ground. You could see men without hands, others without hands and feet, some who had lost their fingers, faces, ears and noses, others crawling around on all fours. There were reports of kind of dragoons sitting on their horses, frozen solid with the rains in their hands,
所以这就是那个家伙因为冻伤而失去脚的故事。一位随瑞典军队同行的路德宗牧师事后写道：“人们嘴里吐出的唾液在落地之前就变成了冰。麻雀从屋顶上被冻僵掉落到地上。你可以看到没有手的男人，其他人没有手和脚，有些人失去了手指、脸庞、耳朵和鼻子，还有的人正四肢着地在地上爬行。有报告称，有些龙骑兵坐在他们的马背上被冻得像冰块一样僵硬，缰绳还握在他们手里，”
and they have to be sort of sawn off to get them off the horse. Oh, God. So in all, perhaps 3,000 men, 3,000 Swedes froze to death. So how large is the force now? Probably well under 30,000, I would have said. That's a sizeable number then. Now the amazing thing is that Charles is still so reckless. Not a scratch, but a trifle as he said to that guy.
人们必须用锯子把他们从马身上锯下来。哦，天哪。所以总共大约有3000人，3000名瑞典人被冻死。那么现在的兵力有多大？我敢说，可能远低于3万。那也算是一个相当可观的数字了。现在令人惊奇的是查理依然如此鲁莽。连皮外伤都没有，简直是小菜一碟，正如他对那家伙说的那样。
Yeah, not a trifle. So in January, he tries to attack. He just to sort of liven things up a bit. He says, well, why don't we attack this course Cossack village nearby? And he sends 3000 men to attack this village and he loses 400 of those men killed and 800 of them wounded, men he can ill afford to lose. And one of the men who is wounded, and this will be important later, is his right hand man who we haven't mentioned yet and we'll talk about him in the next episode, who is
是的，一点也不小菜一碟。所以在1月，他试图发动进攻。他只是为了让局势稍微活跃一点。他说，好吧，我们为什么不进攻附近这个哥萨克村庄呢？他派遣3000人去进攻这个村庄，结果他损失了400名阵亡士兵和800名受伤士兵，这些都是他损失不起的人。而其中一个受伤的人——这在以后会很重要——是他的得力干将，我们还没提到他，我们会在下一集里谈到他，他就是
a guy called Field Marshal Karl Gustav Reinskild and he's hit by shrapnel in the chest and never really recovers. So from this point onwards Charles's right-hand man is is kind of badly wounded. In the middle of February Charles tries to get out of his kind of winter quarters and go move east towards Harkiv but yet more freak weather, thunderstorms, driving rain, floods, he has to go back. And by the time he's ready to move again in April, his men are half starved, they're completely bedraggled. Their boots have rotted, their sodden uniforms are in rags and their gunpowder is so wet that their artillery is basically useless. And also a lot of their artillery, of course, is buried hundreds of miles to the north,
一个名叫卡尔·古斯塔夫·赖恩舍尔d的陆军元帅，他的胸部被弹片击中，从此再也没有真正恢复过。所以从这个时刻开始，查理的得力助手受了重伤。到了2月中旬，查理试图离开他的冬季营地，向东移动前往哈尔科夫，但却遭遇了更多反常的天气：雷暴、狂风暴雨、洪水，他不得不折返。当他在4月份准备再次出发时，他的手下已经半饥半饱，狼狈不堪。他们的靴子已经腐烂，湿漉漉的制服变成了一缕缕破布，他们的火药潮湿得让他们的炮兵基本上形同虚设。而且，他们的许多大炮当然也被埋在了几百英里外的北方，
where what's his name had left them? Yeah, where Count Leuvenhout left them, exactly. Charles, of course, is still very jolly. He sent a letter to our old friend Stanislav Leschinsky and said, my men are in very good condition, and we're very close to winning football. And I think he genuinely believes it. He's so convinced that they can't be beaten and that God is on their side.
也就是谁留在那里的？是的，也就是勒旺豪特伯爵把它们丢下的地方，没错。查理当然依然非常乐观。他给我们的老朋友斯坦尼斯瓦夫·莱什琴斯基写了一封信，说我的部队状态非常好，我们离赢得战争很近了。而且我认为他是发自内心地相信这一点。他如此坚信他们是不可战胜的，上帝站在他们这一边。
It's a road bump. Exactly. It's a bump in the road, but you know, we can see the end of light at the end of the tunnel if I'm not mixing my transport based metaphors. One of his chief advisors, in fact, his, his sort of chief minister is a guy called Count Piper. I don't think it related to the ensign Piper that we began with. He said to him, look, this is really the point where we should give up on this mad scheme.
这只是一个小波折。完全正确。这只是前进道路上的一个小坎儿，但你知道的，如果我没有混淆以交通为基础的比喻的话，我们可以看到隧道尽头的曙光了。他的主要谋士之一，事实上是他的首席大臣，是一个叫派珀伯爵的人。我认为他跟我们开始时提到的派珀少尉没有关系。他对查理说：“听着，这真的是我们应该放弃这个疯狂计划的时候了。”
Why don't we go west back to Poland? And Charles said, no, no, no, no, no. What we actually need is to get reinforcements. And he says, we'll send messengers to Sweden. We will get the Polish Royal Army under Leszczynski to join us. And I'm going to send envoys to the Crimean Tatars because they hate the Russians and once we've got all them on board we can march north and take Moscow just as we thought and the mad thing is that Charles is so confident that when
我们为什么不向西退回波兰呢？查理却说：“不，不，不，不，不。我们真正需要做的是获得增援。”他说，“我们要派信使去瑞典。我们会让莱什琴斯基统帅的波兰王家军队来加入我们。我要派遣特使去克里米亚鞑靼人那里，因为他们痛恨俄罗斯人，一旦我们把他们全部争取过来，我们就可以向北进军并攻占莫斯科，正如我们一直所想的那样。”而疯狂的是，查理竟然自信到这种地步——当
Peter sent a captured Swedish officer to suggest a compromise to say come on now should we have peace should we have a truce? Charles did not even bother to reply because Peter was still saying as part of the compromise, I'd like to keep us in Petersburg. So I said, Oh, well, if you want to keep us in Petersburg, it's no, yeah, nothing to be talked about. There's no way you're going to, you know, I'm going to win this war. It's crazy or heroic depending on your perspective, or maybe both.
彼得派了一名被俘的瑞典军官来提出妥协，说“来吧，我们要不要讲和？要不要停火？”查理甚至懒得回复，因为彼得在妥协的条件中仍然坚持说：“我希望能保留圣彼得堡。”所以查理说：“哦，好吧，如果你想保留圣彼得堡，那就没门了，没什么好谈的。你绝不可能赢这场战争。”这真是既疯狂又英雄主义，取决于你的视角，或者也许两者兼而有之。
One battle can change the course of history and Charles is gambler and gambles sometimes pay off. We did the Battle of Hastings a few weeks ago didn't we and that did change the course of history. And talking of battles where is Charles heading now? So in the end of April Charles says to his men we'll break camp we'll head southeast to a place where we can rendezvous with the Crimeans and with the Poles when they turn up. And the place he has in mind is a small town called Poltava on the bank of the river Vorskla. It's a kind of wooden fortress and it has a Russian garrison, about 5,000 men with cannons.
一场战役就能改变历史的进程，而查理是个赌徒，赌徒的赌注有时会得到回报。我们几周前才做过黑斯廷斯战役的节目，不是吗？那确实改变了历史的进程。说到战役，查理现在正开往何方？所以在4月底，查理对他的手下说：“我们拔营起寨，向东南进发，去一个可以与克里米亚人和波兰人会合的地方，等他们出现的时候。”他脑海中的那个地方是一个叫做波尔塔瓦的小镇，位于沃尔斯克拉河畔。它是一座木质要塞，驻扎着大约5000名带大炮的俄军。
So it's quite like the kind of forts that you get in the American West in the 19th century. Yeah, a little bit. That's exactly how I imagine it. Cause I imagine this landscape having never been to Ukraine. I imagine it as being sort of quite American West kind of nobler's creek. Exactly. So by May 1709, Charles's army is entrenched west of this town. Now this is very unusual for the Swedes cause they don't normally like sieges, a bit like they're Viking forebears actually, and many of Charles's officers are a bit confused why they're
所以这非常像19世纪美国西部的那种堡垒。是的，有点像。这正是我想象中的样子。因为我从来没去过乌克兰，所以我把这里的风景想象成那种相当具有美国西部风情的荒野溪流。完全正确。所以在1709年5月，查理的军队在这个镇子的西边构筑了工事。这对于瑞典人来说非常不寻常，因为他们通常不喜欢围城战，实际上有点像他们的维京祖先，查理的许多军官对于他们为什么要
laying siege to this actually reasonably insignificant fort and the reason they think is that actually the siege is a lure. He's hoping to lure Peter the Great to battle because Charles is confident in a set piece pitch battle he will always win. This siege drags on for six weeks. The weather is now ironically becoming punishingly hot. You can't win. No, you can't. So the Swedes in their rags with their salt and gunpowder are sort of dripping with sweat, being beset by flies. Well, the Swedes don't
围攻这个其实相当无足轻重的堡垒感到有些困惑，而他们认为原因在于，这场围城战其实是一个诱饵。他希望诱使彼得大帝出来决战，因为查理坚信在阵地战中他永远会赢。这场围城战拖了六周之久。讽刺的是，天气现在变得热得令人痛苦。你真是无路可走。不，你确实无路可走。所以身穿破布烂衫、带着受潮火药的瑞典人汗流浃背，还遭到苍蝇的围攻。好吧，瑞典人可不
like heat. They don't like heat. Except in a sauna. I love a Swedish summer as you know I've been on holidays in Sweden. I know you do yeah. I like a Baltic dip I think it's lovely and sunny. I'm good I Swedish tourist board should get in touch. I think it's really nice and sunny and I think it's not too hot and I like that. Yeah kind of one of those white, but a black sky overhead. It's very romantic. Yeah. That's Iceland, a black beach with a black sky. We had it on Gotland.
喜欢炎热。他们不喜欢炎热。桑拿房除外。我喜欢瑞典的夏天，正如你所知，我去过瑞典度假。我知道你喜欢，是的。我喜欢在波罗的海里泡澡，我觉得那里又好又晴朗。我很适合瑞典旅游局应该联系我。我觉得那里真的很好很晴朗，而且我觉得不会太热，我很喜欢那种感觉。是的，那种天空明亮但头顶是黑云的感觉。非常浪漫。是的。那是冰岛，有着黑色沙滩和黑色天空。我们在哥特兰岛上也遇到过。
Did you? Gotland is absolutely gorgeous. I really recommend Gotland to people. We are approaching one of the great battles in world history and here we are talking about Swedish tourist spots. Come on. Discipline. All right.
是吗？哥特兰岛绝对美极了。我真的向大家推荐哥特兰岛。我们正在接近世界历史上最伟大的战役之一，而我们却在这里大谈瑞典的旅游景点。行了，注意纪律。好吧。
So the Swedes are outside Poltava. So think of it this way. The Swedes on the left hand side of the picture as you look at it, then the town, then a river. And then on the right hand side of the picture on the Eastern bank, the Russian army is assembling under Boris Sheremetyev and Alexander Menshikov, who are then joined by Peter the Great. So all the kind of Russian big guns. All the lads. Exactly. Now all this time, Peter's strategy has been to avoid a big battle with the Swedes,
所以瑞典人已经在波尔塔瓦城外了。大家可以这样想象：从画面左侧看过去是瑞典人，接着是城镇，然后是一条河流。再看画面右侧的东岸，俄军正在鲍里斯·谢列梅捷夫和亚历山大·缅什科夫的率领下集结，随后彼得大帝也加入了他们。可以说，所有俄军的大佬和骨干都在这里了。完全正确。而在这期间，彼得的战略一直是避免与瑞典人进行正面大战，
but now he's beginning to rethink. He has about 80,000 men. The Swedes have about 30,000, he thinks. And, you know, many of them with no toes. And they haven't got any gunpowder either. Gunpowder is all, yeah, absolutely dripping with water. Peter's agents have told him that Paltava will probably fall by the end of June. He really needs to strike before that because he doesn't want Charles to get
但现在他开始重新考虑了。他大约有八万军队，而他估计瑞典人大约有三万左右，而且，你知道的，其中许多人连脚趾都冻掉了。他们也没有任何火药，火药全都，是的，绝对都湿透了。彼得的密探告诉他，波尔塔瓦很可能会在六月底前陷落。他真的需要在此之前发动进攻，因为他不想让查理
into the fort and then to use it as a base. So Peter summons his commanders and he says, look, this is the moment. We'll get our army across the river to the Western bank and then we'll unleash our artillery and our weighted numbers against the Swedes. The difficulty is in crossing the river Vorskla. It's a wide, deep and marshy river and he says well we'll cross further north, seven miles north of the town where it's a little bit shallower and we should be able to get across. The Swedes know that the Russians are going to do this, their scouts have reported on it. So by about the 15th and 16th of June they are on full battle alert, their plan is set, Field Marshal Reinskjöld will take care of the Russians, he will let their vanguard across first and then
进入要塞，并将其作为基地。于是彼得召集他的指挥官们说，听着，时机到了。我们要将军队运送到河的西岸，然后对瑞典人倾泻我们的火炮和数量优势。困难在于渡过沃尔斯克拉河。这是一条宽阔、深邃且多沼泽的河流，他说，不过我们可以从更北的地方过河，也就是城北七英里处，那里水浅一些，我们应该能过去。瑞典人知道俄军会这么做，他们的侦察兵已经汇报了。因此，大约在6月15日和16日，他们进入了全面的战斗戒备状态，计划已经制定好，赖恩舍尔德陆军元帅将负责对付俄军，他会先让俄军的前卫部队过河，然后
he will fall on them and destroy them before the rest of the Russian force can join them. It's a good plan. And then the next day, Charles XII's birthday, fate takes a hand. So Charles is turning 27. And so far in these 27 years, he has laughed in the face of danger and death. He's ridden the horses off cliffs. He's wrestled with bears. Yeah, he has gone in full view of Russian gunners and he's had horses shot under him and God has always smiled on him. But the story today on his birthday will be very different. At dawn, he rides out with his elite bodyguard who are called the Drabants to inspect the Swedish defenses on the river.
他会迎头痛击并消灭他们，赶在俄军主力加入之前。这是一个好计划。然后到了第二天，也就是查理十二世的生日，命运之手开始介入了。查理即将年满27岁。在这过去的27年里，他一直对危险和死亡报以轻蔑的微笑。他骑着马从悬崖上跳下，他与熊搏斗。是的，他甚至置身于俄国炮手的众目睽睽之下，坐骑被击中身亡，而上帝总是对他微笑。但今天在他生日这天，故事将会有所不同。黎明时分，他与被称为“近卫军”（Drabants）的精锐保镖一起骑马出营，去巡视河边的瑞典防御工事。
And Russian musketeers, just as usual, on the other side of the river open fire and Charles completely ignores them and he's just turned away to ride his horse back up the bank when a Russian musket ball smacks into the left heel of his boot travels right through his foot and it comes out through his big toe now unbelievably or unbelievably, or indeed, believably, if you've been following Charles' career till now, he doesn't flinch. A Polish nobleman who's with him sees this, but Charles says, don't you dare say a word.
而俄国火枪手像往常一样在河对岸开火，查理完全不理会他们，正准备调转马头顺着河岸骑回去时，一颗俄国火枪弹猛地击中了查理靴子的左后跟，直接穿透了他的脚，从他的大脚趾处穿了出来。现在，令人难以置信的是——或者如果你一直关注查理到目前为止的生平，其实也是可以相信的——他竟然连眼睛都没眨一下。一个同行的波兰贵族看到了这一幕，但查理说：“你敢把这事说出去半个字。”
There goes your foot. Good Lord. So it does. That kind of thing. Exactly. Then he continues the tour of the defenses without saying anything for another three hours. I mean, that is insane, isn't it? I mean, can you imagine? I mean, if I had a blister, I'd be straight back to the camp and demanding medical attention. He's a proper hero in that sense.
你的脚都没了。天哪。确实如此。类似这种事情。完全没错。接着他继续巡视防御工事，三小时内一声不吭。我的天，这太疯狂了吧？我是说，你能想象吗？如果我起个水泡，我早就直奔军营要求医疗救护了。从这个意义上说，他真是个名副其实的英雄。
I mean, if a hero is a kind of someone who is midway between the mortal and the divine, I mean, that is superhuman. This is such Alexander the Great behaviour. Yeah. Isn't it? It's absolute Alexander the Great behaviour. So he gets back to the camp riding his horse, of course, his foot in the stirrup. He is deathly pale when he gets back there and blood is literally oozing out of his boot. And as he tries to dismount, he puts his foot down. The pain is so overwhelmingly agonizing.
我是说，如果英雄是指那种介于凡人和神明之间的人，那这简直就是超人的行径。这完全是亚历山大大帝式的行为。是的。对吧？这绝对是亚历山大大帝式的行为。于是他骑着马回到了军营，当然，脚还踩在马镫里。他回到营地时面色惨白，靴子里正不断渗出血来。当他试图下马时，脚一着地，那痛苦简直剧烈到无以复加。
He collapses in a dead faint and they rush around him. They see there's all his blood pouring out of his boot. His foot has become so swollen. They have to cut his boot off and they find inside the bones of his foot had been shattered and his foot is full of splinters of bone. Oh, you see, I feel like fainting just hearing that. The doctors hesitate when they see this. They're like, Oh my God.
他当场昏死过去，众人连忙围了上来。他们看到大量的血正从他的靴子里涌出。他的脚肿得极其厉害。他们不得不把靴子剪开，结果发现他脚部的骨头已经被震碎了，脚里面塞满了碎骨渣。哦，天哪，光是听到这些我都觉得要晕过去了。医生们看到这一幕犹豫了。他们心想：天哪。
And Charles, this is the best bit. He wakes up, he looks at the doctors as this brilliant line slash away, slash away. And then he picks up a pair of scissors and cuts into his foot himself to open it up for them. I know. So anyone who's prone to kind of, you know, moaning, bear that in mind. Exactly. Think of the Swedish king and man up. So the news spreads through the Swedish camp.
而查理——这是最精彩的部分——他醒了过来，看着医生们，说出了一句绝妙的话：“切掉，切掉！”接着他拿起一把剪刀，自己往脚上剪下去，好帮医生们把伤口剖开。我知道。所以任何爱发牢骚的人，记住这一点。没错。想想瑞典国王，拿出点男子气概来。于是消息传遍了瑞典军营。
The king has been hurt. All this Charles says initially before he passes out, I'll be back in the saddle before you know it. In fact, his foot becomes very badly infected and he comes down with fever. Two days later, the 19th of June, the infection has spread up to his knee and the surgeons want to amputate his leg and the only reason they don't is because they're terrified that when he wakes up he will have them attacked by a bear or something in punishment because the thought of losing his leg would be so dreadful for him. So they don't do it.
国王受伤了。查理在昏过去之前最初说的是：“你们还没回过神来，我就已经重新跨上马背了。”事实上，他的脚感染得非常严重，并发高烧。两天后的6月19日，感染已经蔓延到了他的膝盖，外科医生们想要截肢，他们之所以没有动手，唯一的理由是他们害怕他醒过来后会派一头熊或其他什么东西来攻击他们作为惩罚，因为失去一条腿对查理来说实在是太可怕了。所以他们没有这么做。
By the 21st, two days after that, it is pretty clear to them that he will die within hours. And in fact, at this point, his childhood servant has been summoned to his bedside to read him his favorite boyhood fairy tales. That's nice. Isn't that touching? Now, meanwhile, Field Marshal Reinskild has come back from the river where she was meant to be defending to be with the King and he says to the other officers, look we can't fight this, you know, death or glory battle while the King is lying
到了21日，也就是两天后，他们已经非常清楚他将在几小时内死去。事实上，在这个时候，他儿时的仆人已经被召到床边，为他朗读他最喜爱的童话故事。这挺不错。不是很感人吗？与此同时，赖恩舍尔德陆军元帅从他本该进行防御的河边赶了回来，陪伴在国王身边，他对其他军官说：“听着，我们没法在国王生命垂危时去打这场要么胜利要么死亡的战斗。”
dying. Why not? They're so shaken by the loss of their leader, but also we need to be with him and we need to be on hand when he does die. That's madness. Well, what would he want? He wanted to go and fight. I suppose he would, but they're very loyal, aren't they? But if you're loyal, you obey your king's orders. Well, I just feel Charles is, you know, he's, he's being let down left, right. And center by all his, I suppose, I mean, he's appointed them. So it's his fault to that extent.
为什么不呢？他们因失去领袖而深受打击，但我们也需要陪在他身边，并且在他真的离世时能在场。这太疯狂了。好吧，他会想要什么？他本来就想去打仗。我想他会吧，但他们非常忠诚，不是吗？但如果你忠诚，你就应该服从国王的命令。好吧，我只是觉得查理正在被他周围的所有人左左右右、四面八方地辜负，我想，不过这些都是他任命的人。从这个程度上说，这也是他自己的错。
Oh, right. It's all Charles's fault. Ultimately, is it? That's poor from you to, he's in command. You're absolutely right. Yeah. It's all Charles's fault ultimately, is it? That's poor from you too. Well, he's in command. You're absolutely right. Because while he's lying there on his deathbed, the Russians do cross to the Western Bank. Of course, they're still a long way. They're seven miles north of Poltava, but they're now on the same side of the bank as the Swedes.
哦，对了。这全都是查理的错。归根结底是这样吗？你这话可真够逊的，他才是统帅。你说得完全对。是的。归根结底这全都是查理的错，是吗？你这话也同样很逊。好吧，他才是统帅。你说得完全对。因为正当他躺在病榻上等死的时候，俄军真的渡过了西岸。当然，他们距离还很远，在波尔塔瓦以北七英里处，但他们现在已经和瑞典人在同一侧河岸了。
And they've lost the chance to inflict, you know, a murderous descent on them. Of course. And the Russians have pulled off the most difficult bit of Peter's plan without really facing an enemy shot. Oh, it makes me weep for the Swedes. Then on the 22nd of June, two dramatic developments. First of all, there's sort of movement in Charles's tent and then to the light of his troops. He is brought out on a stretcher.
他们已经错失了对俄军发动致命突袭的时机。当然。而且俄军在几乎没有遭到敌人火力阻击的情况下，就完成了彼得计划中最困难的部分。哦，这让我为瑞典人感到难过。接着在6月22日，发生了两个戏剧性的进展。首先，查理的帐篷里似乎有了一些动静，接着在士兵们的欢呼声中，他被用担架抬了出来。
He is not dead. The fever has broken against all the odds. He is still very weak, but he is alive and he is kind of saluting to them. And then as he's lying there on the stretcher, the messengers arrive from the Poles and the Crimean Tatars. And guess what? The Crimeans aren't coming. Their Ottoman overlords have said no, don't help the Swedes. And what is worse, the Poles aren't coming either. This bloke Stanislaw Fleszczynski, Charles's puppet has completely let him down. He says, Oh, my kingdom is too insecure.
他没有死。高烧退了，打破了所有的悲观预期。他虽然仍然非常虚弱，但他还活着，并且正在向士兵们敬礼。就在他躺在担架上的时候，来自波兰人和克里米亚鞑靼人的信使抵达了。你猜怎么着？克里米亚人不会来了。他们的奥斯曼宗主下令说，不准援助瑞典人。更糟的是，波兰人也不来了。这个叫斯坦尼斯瓦夫·莱什琴斯基的家伙，也就是查理的傀儡，彻底背叛了他。他说：“哦，我的王国太不安全了。”
My rule is a little bit fragile. It'd be reckless for me to send an army to help you now. I mean, he may have a great name, but that's poor behavior. It is poor behavior. So count Piper at this point, the minister, he says to Charles, we must get out of here immediately. This is a disaster. We must head for the river Dnieper, cross it, get into Poland, sign a truce with Peter.
我的统治还有点脆弱。现在派军队去帮你们太轻率了。我是说，他可能有个伟大的名字，但这行为太差劲了。这确实很差劲。于是皮佩尔伯爵这位大臣此时对查理说：“我们必须马上离开这里。这是一场灾难。我们必须前往第聂伯河，渡过河去，进入波兰，与彼得签署停战协定。”
If we have to, we just have to escape with you and the army intact. And Charles says to him, under no circumstances, there'll be no retreat, there's no deal with Peter the Great. Now the thing is, Charles's mental state at this point must be very, I mean that must be very fragile, because he's nearly died, he's only just coming out of a fever, basically the inside of his foot has been shredded. Hasn't eaten a square meal for about 12 months. I wonder if, I mean he's almost died but he hasn't.
如果必须的话，我们只能带着你和完好的军队逃跑。”而查理对他说：“绝无可能，决不撤退，也绝不与彼得大帝达成交易。”问题是，此时查理的精神状态一定非常——我是说一定非常脆弱，因为他差点死去，高烧刚刚退去，基本上他的脚底内部已经被撕裂了。而且他大概有12个月没吃过一顿正经饭了。我在想，我是说他差点死了，但他没死。
Has God preserved him? I think there's a big element of that. I think he's sitting there probably with a kind of sheen of cold sweat on his face. Thinking, I've cheated death once again, fate has spared me for higher things. And I think he also thinks enough of this now. You know, Peter is only seven miles away. Let's finish this. Let's have the pitch battle that I've always wanted. I don't think he ever doubts that he will win it. Because on the Sunday, the 27th of June, five days later, they have
是上帝保佑了他吗？我认为这里面有很大一部分原因。我想他当时可能坐在那里，脸上带着一层冷汗。心里想着：我又一次战胜了死神，命运留我下来是为了完成更伟大的事业。我想他也觉得够了。你知道，彼得就在七英里外。结束这一切吧。让我们进行我一直渴望的那场正面大战吧。我觉得他从来没有怀疑过自己会赢。因为到了星期天，也就是6月27日，五天后，他们举行了
their morning prayers and then he calls his generals to his bedside. He says, the Russians may have the greater numbers, but we have the experience, we have the tactics, and we have God's support. If we take them unawares, if we strike first, we can trap them against the river, we can smash their army, and we could maybe even capture Peter himself. And if we do that, then we win the war, you know, in a morning. And he says tomorrow outside Poltava, we will have the final showdown to decide the fate of Northern Eastern Europe. Tom, the winner takes it all.
晨祷，然后他把将领们召集到病榻前。他说：“俄国人可能人多势众，但我们有经验，我们有战术，我们还有上帝的支持。如果我们出其不意，如果我们先发制人，我们就能把他们逼到河边，我们就能粉碎他们的军队，甚至可能生擒彼得本人。如果我们做到了这一点，那么我们就在一个早晨赢得了这场战争。”他说，明天在波尔塔瓦城外，我们将迎来决定整个东北欧命运的最终对决。汤姆，赢者通吃。
The loser has to fall. We'll be standing small. Yeah. Yeah. And so it is that in the early hours of the following morning, the final showdown, the battle of Poltava begins. Well, who will win it? There's only one way to find out.
败者黯然离场。我们将会孤立无援。对的。对的。就这样，在第二天清晨，最终的对决——波尔塔瓦战役开始了。好吧，谁会获胜呢？只有一个方法可以知道。
And that is if you are a member of the Restless History Club to go on and listen to our account of this epic battle right away. If you are not, then you can still do that by heading to the rest is history.com and signing up or you can wait until next week. Yeah, don't wait. But whatever you choose, we will be back next time for the final showdown. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. Hi everybody, you're still here.
那就是如果你是“历史余音”俱乐部的会员，就可以直接去收听我们对这场史诗般战役的详尽解说。如果你还不是，你仍然可以通过访问therestishistory.com并注册来做到这一点，或者你可以等到下周。是的，不要等待。但无论你选择什么，我们下次都会回来进行最终的对决。再见。再见。再见。大家好，你们还在。
Right at the end of the episode I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what? I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that there is of course only one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the
就在节目的最后，我对你们的执着深表钦佩。但听着，我有个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些节目里的广告吗？你们有时会想，你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众听的是关于我品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你这么想过，那么当然只有一个方法能体验到那种感觉。你可以打断广告的进程。
next HSBC Premier or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on The Rest Is History. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded listeners by advertising on The Rest Is History and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. If you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest, or indeed your company's interest, by going to Goalhanger.com
成为下一个汇丰卓越理财（HSBC Premier）或曾在《历史余音》上做过广告的许多其他伟大公司之一。通过在《历史余音》以及目标挂钩网络（Goalhanger Network）的其他节目上投放广告，你可以将你的品牌展现在数百万志同道合的听众面前。现在你可能会想，我不知道什么是目标挂钩网络。Goalhanger就是制作这个节目的公司。如果你正盘算着提升你品牌的价值，Goalhanger非常希望能听到你的声音。你可以通过访问Goalhanger.com
right now. And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在就注册你的意向，或者你公司的意向。拼写是Goal，G-O-A-L，Hangar，H-A-N-G-E-R，点com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。